Wir haben heute das Mandat erhalten, Verhandlungen innerhalb der klaren Eckpunkte zu führen und einen Abschluss durch das Präsidium vorzubereiten.
Wir haben in den vergangenen Monaten sehr viele und sehr intensive Gespräche mit unseren aktuellen Medienpartnern und möglichen weiteren Interessenten darüber geführt. Auch in Richtung dieser Medienunternehmen ist der heutige Beschluss ein wichtiges Signal.
Es ist kein Anteilsverkauf an der DFL, sondern eine Erlöstbeteiligung mit sehr klaren roten Linien. Wir werden mit diesem Mandat, und das sehr ausdrücklich, sehr verantwortungsvoll umgehen. Uns ist durchaus bewusst, dass das für die Gesamtausrichtung der Liga eine sehr zentrale Partnerschaft ist.
Das Tribünengespräch.
Preisfrage, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, wen habt ihr da gerade gehört? 3, 2, 1, Steffen Merkel und Mark Lenz. Und wer sind diese beiden Herren? Das müsst ihr aber nun wirklich wissen, die Geschäftsführer der DFL. Dass die Namen nicht so präsent sind, ist aber vielleicht schon Teil der Geschichte, über die wir heute sprechen wollen. Ihr hört hier Teil 2 unserer Tribünengespräch-Saga, keine Ahnung, wie viele Teile es noch geben wird, zum Einstieg eines Investors bei der deutschen Fußballliga. Und dazu heiße ich euch ganz herzlich willkommen. Mein Name ist Max Jakob Ost. Ich bin der Ed Genetzer auf mastodon.social und bei Blue Sky. Und wie schon in Teil 1 habe ich Marcus Bark hier von der Sportschau. Hallo, Markus. Unter anderem natürlich nur von der Sportschau. Du bist ja ein Tausend, Sasser. Und ähnlich ist es bei Chaled Nahar. Hallo, Chaled. Schön, dass du da bist.
Hallo aus Köln.
Grüße euch. Na, habt ihr Lust, ein bisschen wieder über Investoren-Dinge zu sprechen? Warte, da habe ich später noch was vorbereitet. Das feuere ich noch nicht jetzt ab, das können wir nicht machen. Also, um kurz alle ins Boot zu holen, ihr könnt als Vorbereitung oder ihr solltet als Vorbereitung das erste Gespräch gehört haben. Da haben wir nämlich all das, was im Frühjahr passiert ist, aufgearbeitet. Also es gab ja schon mal Diskussionen um einen Einstieg eines Investors in die DFL und um was es genau da geht, um welche Summen und was dagegen und dafür spricht und vor allem wie auch die Situation in anderen Ländern ist. Das haben wir im Frühjahr ausführlich besprochen. Das würden wir jetzt hier nicht nochmal machen. Heute konzentrieren wir uns auf den zweiten Anlauf, in dem es jetzt dann doch geklappt hat, wenn auch mit der knappest aller möglichen Abstimmungsergebnisse. Lasst uns mal einfach bei dem gestrigen Tag beginnen. Ihr wart beide in Frankfurt. Ihr wart sowieso zusammen mit Benni Hofmann zum Beispiel noch vom Kicker. Herzliche Grüße wart ihr so die Frontberichterstatter, würde ich fast sagen, in dieser Investorengeschichte, wenn man Informationen haben wollte. Bei euch hat man sie bekommen auf sportschau.de und auf kicker.de gab es auch eine Themenseite. Ihr wart beide gestern, Chaled, in Frankfurt. Wie war es denn?
Ja, also ich fand es unglaublich spannend erst mal. Also ich fand es war für mich das erste Mal, dass ich dann live dabei war bei der Mitgliederversammlung. Und also ich war nicht drin, wir waren mehr draußen gewartet. Es war halt immer interessant, wenn jemand rauskam. Und wie sieht es aus? Wie sieht es aus? Ja genau, die Toilettengänge waren dann das Spannende. Also das war dann, als auch die ersten zum zweiten Mal aufs Klo gingen, hast du schon gemerkt, okay, das dauert ein bisschen. Dann ging so ein Gerücht um über eine Probeabstimmung, die halt mit 24 zu 12 ausgegangen war. Und das erhärtete sich dann später. Und dann kam das Abstimmungsergebnis 24 zu 12. Kann man ja fast sagen, das ist natürlich zehnmal Nein und zweimal Enthaltung. Aber eine Enthaltung hat ja die gleiche Wirkung letztendlich, weil sie ja 24 Ja-Stimmen brauchten. Und genau die haben sie strichgenau bekommen.
Das kann man wohl sagen. Also kurz zur Erklärung. Die 36 Vereine, in der der ersten beiden liegen, die haben abgestimmt. Eine Zweidrittelmehrheit braucht man mindestens für eine solche Entscheidung, wie eben den Investoreneinstieg. Und die hat man eben mit den 24 genau erreicht. Und deswegen entzahlen aber Enthaltungen genauso wie ein Nein, weil du brauchst eben Ja-Stimmen. Du brauchst die 24 Ja-Stimmen oder mehr, um einen Beschluss zu fassen. Jetzt hat es genau mit den 24 geklappt. Marcus, es war für uns sehr schwierig, als Beobachter vorher zu sagen, was da passiert. Und man hatte den Eindruck, das hat sich, also wahrscheinlich auch deswegen die Probeabstimmung. Ich habe das Gefühl, es war eine unheimliche Nervosität zu spüren bei allen Beteiligten. Geht dir das ähnlich?
Absolut. Das war auch aus den Gesprächen vorher herauszuhören. Es gab Leute, die gesagt haben, ich bin mir sicher oder ziemlich sicher, dass das Ding scheitert. Es gab Leute, die gesagt haben, das geht durch. Dann gab es Leute, die gesagt haben, 50-50, also jetzt nicht 50-50 in der Abstimmung, sondern dass es durchgeht oder Spitz auf Knopf und so war es ja dann auch. Tatsächlich ganz aktuell, ich hoffe nicht, das konnte man natürlich nicht sehen, was ich aufs Handy geguckt habe. Ich habe tatsächlich noch die Info bekommen, dass die zweite Liga gar keine Probeabstimmung gemacht hat und die erste wohl nur mit Hand heben. Das wirft noch mehr Fragen auf, weil wie kommt man bei einer Probeabstimmung nur von 18 Bundesligisten auf ein Stimmverhältnis von 24-12? Aber gut, es muss uns ja auch nicht immer die Wahrheit gesagt werden. Chaled hat es ja mitgekriegt. Wir haben gestern von der Probeabstimmung gehört, zwei, drei Leute gefragt, was ist mit Probeabstimmung und da haben ja tatsächlich welche gesagt, gab keine. Gibt keine, weiß ich nichts von. Also was da genau passiert ist, ist weiterhin offen. Das Abstimmungsergebnis ist natürlich bekannt, aber unter dem großen Vorbehalt Hannover 96.
Wir haben ja quasi mehr oder weniger das Thema live getickert, kann man fast sagen. Und ich glaube, vielleicht hatten halt auch Leute Sorge, dann irgendwie diesen Prozess dann auf den letzten Mittag zu torpedieren, wenn irgendetwas nach außen dringt, im Sinne von also die, die gesagt haben, ne Probeabstimmung weiß ich nichts von, kann man jetzt im Nachhinein gut einsortieren, glaube ich.
Ja, also über Hannover 96 werden wir auf jeden Fall noch mal ausführlicher sprechen müssen in dieser Sendung oder es zumindest kurz anreißen müssen. Aber die erste Frage, die ich mir jetzt gerade gestellt habe, haben denn die Erstlegisten und die Zweitlegisten in der ersten Runde getrennt miteinander sich vorbereitet auf diese Sitzung, wenn es zwei getrennte Probeabstimmungen, also wenn das überhaupt eine Möglichkeit war. Ich dachte, die sitzen alle in einem Raum.
Es gab Teilversammlungen.
Okay.
Sogenannte Teilversammlung vor der Versammlung, die um 11 Uhr anfangen sollte. Das hat sich ein bisschen verzögert. Lag mit Sicherheit nicht an der zweiten Liga, weil die waren ziemlich schnell durch.
Die zweite Liga, das klang zuerst, als würden nur die sich vorher zur Teilversammlung treffen. Es waren aber beide. Also beide Ligen haben quasi jeweils sich isoliert getroffen. Und mit der Probeabstimmung, ich nehme mal an, dass die in der großen Versammlung aber auch nochmal stattgefunden haben wird, weil sonst kommt man ja auch gar nicht auf diese Ergebnisse. Aber wie gesagt, was in Frankfurt passiert bleibt in Frankfurt, ist da die Maßgabe größtenteils und...
Naja, meiner Erfahrung nach kommt das in den nächsten Wochen alles hinterhier draußen. Aber für den Moment bleibt es vielleicht in Frankfurt. Das kann sein, bis alle wieder wach sind und man ein paar Telefonate führen kann. Jetzt haben wir, um kurz bei diesem Ergebnis zu bleiben, also es war eben das knappeste aller möglichen Ergebnisse, das dafür stimmt. Also jetzt kann man über einen Investoreneinstieg verhandeln, in konkrete Gespräche gehen. Was das genau heißt, das müssen wir gleich noch besprechen. Jetzt war es aber ja so, und das war ja auch eine der ersten Fragen in der Pressekonferenz, die dann anschließend stattfand, dass es im Frühjahr noch hieß, Markus, also eine knappe Zweidrittelmehrheit, das wird uns nicht reichen, um so eine Entscheidung zu treffen. Jetzt ging das auf einmal doch und die Antwort darauf, die war so ein bisschen, also bei mir ist da nichts hängen geblieben. Also in meinen Notizen steht, dass manche Clubs positiv waren, aber durften nicht zustimmen wegen der Gegebenheiten. Das war so eine kleine Spitze, sollten wir uns gleich noch mal genau anhören. Den Ton habe ich ja auch dabei. Aber wie empfindest du denn das, dass man quasi auch da jetzt eine Veränderung gesehen hat zum Frühjahr? Im Frühjahr hieß es, ne, wenn, dann müssen wir das alle wollen, und zwar wirklich fast alle. Und jetzt sagt man, naja, wir haben ja nur 66 Prozent gebraucht, oder die zwei Drittelmehrheit, die haben wir gekriegt, also go for it.
Ich glaube, das war einfach jetzt die letzte Chance. Jetzt oder nie war da das Motto, wenn das gestern in die Buchse gegangen wäre, dann hätten man das Projekt beerdigen können. Und das hat Watzke ja nach der ersten oder nicht nach der ersten, aber nach der Nummer im Mai auch gesagt, dass das jetzt erst mal für lange Zeit beendet ist. Und jetzt haben sie es doch wieder so schnell auf die Tagesordnung genommen. Und letztlich war denen jetzt völlig egal, ob 24 oder 27. Die wollten es jetzt durchdrücken, weil die Bedingungen, das ist natürlich schwer nachzuprüfen. Aber die Rechnung von Union Berlin, die macht ja insofern schon Sinn, wenn man mal die genauen Zahlen weglässt. Die Bedingungen sind ja schlechter geworden. Sinsentwicklung, alles Mögliche, bla, bla, bla. Also das war jetzt die letzte Chance der Befürworter, den Investor ins Boot zu holen. Und da reicht dann halt auch die statutarische oder statuarische Mehrheit.
Die den Statuten gemäße und benötigte Mehrheit.
Immer dran vorbeischreiben an den schwierigen Wörtern. Das ist die große Kunst.
Ja, aber wirklich. Also über das Abstimmungsverhalten, glaube ich, sollten wir uns dann auch noch übersprechen. Aber vielleicht ist das jetzt, bevor wir zu tief in die Details reingehen, vielleicht sollten wir erst noch mal für diejenigen erklären, die jetzt nicht die Möglichkeit hatten, eurem Live-Ticker zu folgen. Um was geht es jetzt eigentlich in dieser Runde? Chaled, wir wissen, im Frühjahr war immer so zwei Milliarden die große Summe, die im Raum stand. Jetzt ist die Summe, zumindest die, die man so ganz grob transportiert, so ganz, stimmt es ja vielleicht sogar gar nicht, eine Milliarde. Kannst du uns mal kurz erklären, was hat sich denn verändert vom Frühjahr jetzt hin zu dieser Entscheidung?
Ja, im Grunde geht es um drei Kennzahlen jeweils, das kann man sagen. Also was im Frühjahr wie heute gleich ist, die Laufzeit und es ist wichtig, sehr wichtig, dass es sie gibt, beträgt 20 Jahre. Nach 20 Jahren soll dieser Vertrag enden und die Rechte an die DFL zurückfallen. So schlau war man in Frankreich nicht zum Beispiel, die haben so einen ähnlichen Deal gemacht ohne Laufzeit, die zahlen jetzt ihr Leben lang das Geld.
Was wirklich unfassbar ist.
Es ist fantastisch. Aber diese, also 20 Jahre, das ist eine wichtige Kennzahl. Die zweite wichtige Kennzahl hast du schon gesagt, die Einmalzahlung des Investors, die aber auch nicht auf einmal gezahlt wird, sondern in bestimmten Branchen, beträgt jetzt statt 2 Milliarden im Mai, 1 Milliarde ist das Ziel, könnten auch 900 Millionen werden. Also das ist halt immer so ein bisschen noch in der Schwebe. Das muss ja noch ausverhandelt werden. Und die dritte wichtige Kennzahl ist halt, wie viel Prozent der Einnahmen aus den Vermarktungseinnahmen also werden quasi an den Investor jetzt künftig abgedrückt. Und das waren 12,5 Prozent im Mai und jetzt sollen es maximal 8 Prozent werden. Und man muss da kein großer Mathe-Professor sein. Ich hatte jetzt auch das Laber Abi Deutsch und Geschichte, aber das 8 Prozent, eine Milliarde ist natürlich eine schlechtere Kondition als zwei Milliarden für 12,5 Prozent. Das ist ja völlig klar. Das heißt, der Preis ist runter und das ist ja auch der Grund gewesen, warum oder ein Grund gewesen, warum Union Berlin sich dazu kritisch geäußert hat, die ja vorher völlige Befürworter waren.
Also die haben es auch ausgerechnet auf einen Prozentpunkt runter. Das ist jetzt eine sehr einfache Rechnung, aber kann man schon machen. Im Frühjahr waren es noch 176 Millionen Euro für einen Prozentpunkt. Jetzt sind es 112 Millionen Euro, also über 50 Millionen Euro weniger, weit sogar über 50 Millionen Euro weniger. Marcus, wie würdest du denn auf diese Veränderung im Deal, wie würdest du das einordnen? Zum Teil ist es ja auch die Reaktion auf Kritik an der Ablehnung im Frühjahr, weil wir werden dann noch über die Verwendung der Mittel sprechen. Aber wenn man sich anguckt, wo ist denn quasi die Milliarde hin, die man ursprünglich haben wollte? Ach so, das waren so viele Zahlungen, die man eigentlich an die Clubs direkt geben wollte.
Ich glaube, das kann man sagen, ohne dabei gewesen zu sein. Das liest sich ja auch aus vielen Statements raus. Wenn die den Topf zur freien Verfügung nicht entfernt hätten, wäre das Ding nie durchgegangen. Ein bestes Beispiel ist der KSC, der im Mai noch dagegen gestimmt hat, gestern dafür. Und wir haben gesagt, zwei Hauptkritikpunkte sind weg. Der eine, den gab es bei vielen anderen auch. Wir haben dieses Mal eine Geschäftsführung, eine dauerhafte Geschäftsführung mit Lenz und Merkel und nicht wie im Mai mit Lecky und Hellmann, eine Interimsgeschäftsführung. Und der andere, der wesentliche Punkt war, es gibt keinen Topf, der einfach so nach aktuell gürtigen TV-Schlüssel an die Vereine verteilt wird zur freien Verfügung, sondern wir sammeln das Geld hauptsächlich dafür ein, dass alle davon profitieren. Und wenn die DFL diesem Kompromiss nicht eingegangen wäre, dann bin ich ganz stark davon überzeugt, dass es auch gestern nicht die notwendige Mehrheit gegeben hätte.
Ich glaube, was man dazu sagen muss, das sind halt zwei zentrale Kritikpunkte und ich habe viel mit Kritikern und Befürwortern unter den Clubs auch gesprochen. Und dieses Thema mit dem Geld, klar, das ist die erste und die wichtigste Antwort, warum das jetzt zustimmungsfähiger war, dass das Geld nicht so massiv in die Clubs fließt und auch da natürlich wieder nach oben vor allem. Das Argument aber mit der bestellten Geschäftsführung, man hat wirklich gemerkt, dass das vielen sehr, sehr wichtig war. Das habe ich auch glaube ich damals im Nachhinein als Punkt so ein bisschen unterschätzt und wir erinnern uns an die legendäre Pressekonferenz mit Watzke. Da hat er genau diesen Punkt als Bullshit wortwörtlich beiseite geschoben. In der Vorbereitung auf den jetzigen Termin hat man aber echt gemerkt, dass das wirklich ein Thema war. Also das hat man immer wieder gehört.
Das muss man auch sagen, auch Vertreter von Vereinen, die mit Nein gestimmt haben, haben die Arbeit von Lenz und Merkel doch gelobt. Also das war schon transparenter, weiß ich nicht, aber es war bemühter. Also sie haben sich sehr darum gekümmert, sie haben dann hinterhertelefoniert, wenn noch Fragen waren und so. Ich glaube, um es überspitzt zu sagen, im Mai sollte was von oben drauf gedrückt werden auf alle und auch jetzt wurde erklärt, das haben wir vor und das hat nicht alle überzeugt, aber sie haben es zumindest verstanden.
Ja, das Gefühl hatte ich auch in den Gesprächen, die ich so hatte. Ich finde, man hat es auch auf der Pressekonferenz gemerkt, es war jetzt nicht schwierig, einen anderen Ton anzuschlagen als Aki Watzke, der ja totis beleidigt war und extrem polemisch haben wir in der letzten Sendung aufgearbeitet und da habe ich ja damals gar nicht alle O-Töne abgespielt, die ich hier noch gehabt hätte, aber man hat es auch daran gemerkt, die haben einen anderen Ton und vielleicht auch, das ist so ein schwieriges Argument, weil da gibt es keinerlei Beweise für, aber ich habe schon im Frühjahr immer wieder auch so unterschwellig gehört von Menschen aus dem Bundesliga-Betrieb, die gesagt haben, vielleicht machen das Hellmann und Legy auch ein bisschen für sich, vielleicht ist das quasi so der Plan, dann da in die Media Co, dann da als Geschäftsführer reinzugehen und so weiter und so fort. Das sind natürlich reine Unterstellungen, es gibt dafür keinerlei Anhaltspunkte, aber jetzt kommt es eben aus der DFL heraus. Steffen Merkel und Mark Lenz, die waren beide schon in der DFL tätig, auch in den Bereichen, die jetzt relevant sind für diese Entscheidung und da hat das, glaube ich, auch einen ganz anderen Anklang, wenn diejenigen dann quasi, sie müssen ja intern die größten Trommler für das Projekt sein und da versteht man das aber auch, glaube ich. Und vielleicht ist das auch ein guter Moment, um mal Mark Lenz zu Wort kommen zu lassen. Das ist ein O-Ton aus der Pressekonferenz, denn er hat in seinem Eingangsstatement die drei Kernänderungen beschrieben, die man eben vollzogen habe im Vergleich zum Versuch im Frühjahr und vielleicht klopfen wir die einfach mal ab, ob wir sagen, alle davon wurden auch wirklich erreicht.
Drei Kernänderungen waren es, die wir durchgeführt haben. Erste Änderung, Fokussierung auf den Kapitalbedarf der DFL. Das heißt, anvisiert sind Investitionen in das Medienprodukt, die Digitalisierung und Internationalisierung der Gesamtliga. Zweite Änderung betrifft die Governance. Und hier war es uns in der Geschäftsführung sehr wichtig, die besagten roten Linien nicht nur detailliert mit den Clubs zu besprechen, sondern diese auch vor dem heutigen Votum bereits mit den Bietern und von den Bietern bestätigen zu lassen. Das heißt, Zugriff auf sportliche Themen waren und sind ohnehin immer ausgeschlossen. Die Mitspracherechte eines Partners fokussieren sich maximal auf den wirtschaftlichen Bereich und sind klar limitiert. Das heißt, Clubs haben stets die relevante Entscheidungshoheit. Dritte Änderung war für uns die Thematik der umfassenden Transparenz. Das ist selbstverständlich gegenüber den Clubs, mit denen wir sehr intensive und detaillierte Befassungen hatten. Es war aber auch die klare Transparenz zum einen gegenüber Bietern. Das heißt, kein Taktieren, sondern sehr klar entweder Akzeptanz unserer genannten roten Linien oder es ist dementsprechend nicht der richtige Partner. Zudem klare Transparenz gegenüber der Öffentlichkeit, um zum einen zu informieren, zum anderen aber auch auf Basis der Fakten dieses Modell zu diskutieren.
So, drei Kernaussagen und jetzt werfe ich die euch zum Fraß vor. Mit Kernaussage 1, da haben wir schon so ein bisschen grob begonnen. Fokussierung auf den Kapitalbedarf der DFL. Man kann bei euch, Chaled, nachlesen auf sportschau.de. Werde ich natürlich alles verlinken, wofür das Geld jetzt verwendet werden soll, wenn es dann erstmal da ist. Also es muss jetzt erstmal mit einem Interessent gesprochen werden, aber da ist man eigentlich schon relativ weit. Da kommen wir glaube ich im Punkt 2 nochmal mit dazu. Aber kannst du uns einmal kurz erklären, was will man denn mit der Kohle machen und findest du, dass dann diese Kernänderung, Fokussierung auf den Kapitalbedarf der DFL und eben weg vom Kapitalbedarf der Clubs, die den vielleicht für Spieler, Spielerberater und so weiter brauchen, dass du das als erfüllt ansiehst?
Ja von dem, was wir wissen, muss man das natürlich bejahen. Also das, was ich eben angesprochen habe mit der Transparenz, das ist natürlich schon was ganz anderes gewesen. Also diese Salami-Nummer vom letzten Mal, hier ist noch ein Topf, da ist noch ein Topf. Dann kamen erst diese Ausgleichszahlungen später raus, dass es die geben soll und so weiter. Also es kam alles so schreibchenweise auch mit dem Infrastruktur-Topf, der dann plötzlich doch nicht nur für Infrastruktur da sein sollte. Also das haben sie abgeräumt und man muss auch sagen, wenn man mit Kritikern gesprochen hat, Lenz und Merkel genießen wirklich eine Menge Vertrauen. Das kann man glaube ich so sagen auch unter den Clubs, das ist auch durchgekommen. Jetzt zur eigentlichen Frage, was passiert mit dem Geld. Also eine Milliarde muss man erstmal in drei Bereiche aufteilen. 300 Millionen, das ist erstmal das einfachste. Das Geld des Investors wird dafür genutzt, das Loch zu stopfen, dass der Investorendeal reißt. Also acht Prozent pro Jahr sind jetzt weg 20 Jahre lang und in den ersten vier bis fünf Jahren sollen diese 300 Millionen dafür herhalten, das Loch bei den Clubs zu stopfen, damit das sich nicht so bemerkbar macht bei den Einnahmen. 100 Millionen sollen für Auslandsreisen draufgehen. Das sehen wir gerade immer wieder, wie andere Ligen das machen. Also die Premier League hat die Summer Series in den USA veranstaltet. Die Spanier machen ein eigenes Turnier in den USA auch. Und da will die DFL auch so ein bisschen unternehmerischer vorgehen, sage ich mal, dass sie das ein bisschen besser koordinieren und vielleicht auch so eine Turnierform im Sommer oder irgendwas gemeinschaftliches hinkriegen, weil es bringt halt nichts, wenn einmal im Leben Paderborn und einmal im Leben Köln und einmal im Leben Stuttgart in die USA fahren und dann sich wundern, dass es nicht mehr Geld gibt. Also das muss natürlich dauerhaft und mehrfach und strukturierter und unternehmerisch geplanter passieren. Und dafür sind diese 100 Millionen auch da.
Ob sich das dann lohnt, wenn dann Paderborn, Köln und Augsburg gegeneinander ein Summer Series Turnier machen?
Da kann man drüber streiten, das ist mir klar. Aber auf jeden Fall ist es so schon mal sinnvoll, irgendein Publikum dort zu binden, wenn man das denn möchte. Interessant wird es dann halt bei diesen restlichen 600 Millionen. Also wir gehen jetzt weiterhin von der Milliarde aus. Das ist ja auch einfacher zu rechnen, das macht es halt leichter. Und da gibt es halt so einen Investitionsplan von der DFL, den ich bekommen habe. Und da gibt es unterschiedliche Posten. Und was halt als erstes auffällt, diese digitale Plattform, die ja immer der vornehmliche Punkt war, worum es da geht, die ist offenbar gar nicht mal so teuer, wie man gedacht hat. Da sind 164 Millionen für veranschlagt, für diesen Digitalbereich. Es hieß immer, die 600 Millionen seien vornehmlich dafür da. Ist aber nur, also das läuft unter einem Punkt digital, Direct-to-Consumer, so heißt das bei dieser Plattform. Da ist sie in den 164 Millionen mit eingepreist. Da soll dann auch ein internationaler Fanshop rein. Dann steht da was von Reichweitenaufbau. Ich nehme an, da geht es dann so um Nutzerkonten etc. Also dafür sind 164 von den 600 Millionen eingeplant.
Was ja die Kritik aus dem Frühjahr eigentlich gerechtfertigt, wo damals schon einige gesagt haben, warum braucht man 600 Millionen Euro, um eine digitale Plattform einzurichten?
Da sieht man aber halt auch, dass das Geld noch für ganz andere Dinge genutzt wird. Und dann ist ein weiterer Punkt, da ist auch der dickste Batzen dabei, ist Internationalisierung, 183 Millionen, also es ist jetzt halt so genau, steht das da. Aber wir wissen ja noch nicht, ob es die Milliarde wird, aber man kann das dann auch fast so im Verhältnis sehen natürlich, quasi prozentual. Also 183 Millionen von den 600 Millionen sollen für Internationales draufgehen. Diese 100 Millionen, das sind glaube ich so Sachen, dass vor allem die Reisekosten unterstützt werden, sage ich mal. Und bei den 183 Millionen geht es dann darum, da stehen so Sachen wie Freundschaftsspiele und Turniere zu organisieren, zu unterstützen. Dann ist die Rede von einem Legenden-Netzwerk. Ich weiß jetzt nicht, ob dann irgendwie beispielsweise Jürgen Koder nach Tokio geschickt wird, um für die Bundesliga Werbung zu machen, keine Ahnung, was da. Das ist nicht genauer erläutert. Dann gibt es aber auch darum, international zu kommunizieren. Also stell dir vor, du brauchst halt Social-Kanäle in verschiedenen Sprachen häufiger vielleicht. Das haben natürlich vor allem die großen Clubs, die kleinen vielleicht noch nicht so. Dann geht es um internationale Büros, dass du halt, ich glaube, die DFL hat ein Büro in Singapur und eins in, ist es New York? So und auch das soll dann dabei ausgebaut werden. So und dann auch noch interessant ist der nationale Topf sozusagen, der da drin ist, mit 126 Millionen. Da geht es um Produktideen und Weiterentwicklung, rechte Schutz, das soll wohl zum einen heißen, ja irgendwie das Produkt insgesamt voranzubringen, aber halt auch vor allem sicherzustellen, dass nicht weiter Piraterie mit illegalen Streams irgendwie betrieben wird, wie man dagegen vorgehen will, weiß ich nicht, aber das soll eine Möglichkeit sein, um halt wieder mehr Geld bei der DFL zu haben, dass die Leute halt legal und bezahlt die Bundesliga gucken, also diejenigen, die es halt nicht legal tun. Und weiter steht da Innovationen, TV-Produktion. Damit ist natürlich gemeint, neue Kameraperspektiven, aber auch so Dinge werden da drin stecken, wie die viel zitierten Kabinenvideos, Videos aus dem Mannschaftsbus, Interviews kurz vor dem Spiel, sich solche Dinge zu überlegen. Das hat man ja in Spanien gesehen, da wird das ja schon konkret umgesetzt. Die haben ja auch schon so ein Private Equity Deal, wobei jetzt der nicht unbedingt mit solchen Ideen zusammenhängt. Ich meine, die DFL hat Sportcast als Produktionsfirma, da ist ja eine richtige Ideenspiele da. Die haben halt immer diese Sports Innovation, diese Messe. Das ist ja eine Spielzeugmesse quasi für TV-Technik. Also die Ideen liegen da, die müssen dann nur finanziert werden, glaube ich. Und in Spanien gibt es zum Beispiel Kabinenvideos, da kriegen die extra Geld, die Klubs, die mitmachen. Und Athletic Bilbao überträgt da live aus der Kabine, wie die Mannschaft vor dem Spiel das Vaterunser betet. Also das gibt es halt auch bei Twitter, das Video, das kann man sich da mal anschauen, wie das abläuft. Und das ist auch nicht ganz frei von Konflikten. Also einigen Spielern gefällt das nicht. Ich glaube, der Torwart hat sich sehr kritisch geäußert dazu. Und ein weiterer Punkt in diesem Topf ist eine sogenannte liegweite Dokumentation. Und ich denke, das ist dann sowas Netflix-artiges mit gemeint, so wie Drive to Survive in der Formel 1 und halt viele Sportarten gehen diesen Weg. Radsport hat einige Dokumentationen veröffentlicht. Leichtathletik plant auf diesem Weg, den Menschen Hammer werfen und Sperrwurf schmackhaft zu machen. Genau, Tennis, wie hieß es? Tiebreak oder Breakpoint oder so. Also das sind diese Sachen. So und was halt noch auffällt ist, es gibt noch einen Topf, der heißt Commercial Partnerships, 65 Millionen. Ich bin bald durch, keine Sorge. Da geht es darum, Partner zu binden. Da steht es vor allem als größter Kostenpunkt in dem Bereich virtuelle Werbung. Damit wird wahrscheinlich gemeint sein, dass man halt die Bandenwerbung je nach Land austauschen kann. Also dass man halt nicht für den Baumarkt in Köln-Zollstock wirbt, wenn das Spiel nach Tokio übertragen wird oder so. Das ergibt ja keinen Sinn.
Was ja zum Teil aber jetzt schon passiert, also das hat mich ehrlicherweise gewundert, dass man das jetzt noch machen muss. Augsburg zum Beispiel hat das schon. Da hast du dann nämlich irgendwelche chinesischen Wettboden, die da angezeigt werden im internationalen Bild, die du im Deutschen gar nicht siehst, weil da steht halt dann irgendwie, ja, irgendein deutscher Baumarkt.
Vielleicht geht es auch nicht nur um Bandenwerbung. Da gibt es ja noch andere Sachen, also wie man die einblenden kann. Das ist ja eine Menge möglich. Und ohne jegliche Kosten genannt steht da Bundesliga-Namensrecht, Umsetzung, Partnerschaft. Mehr steht dazu nicht, das kann man nur so im Raum stehen lassen. Könnte aber sein, dass wir bald eine vermarktete Bundesliga, was ihren Namen angeht, haben. Und das sind, glaube ich, jetzt so zusammengefasst die wesentlichen Punkte, was da vorgesehen ist, wo das Geld hingehen soll.
Ja genau, also ein bisschen was behält man noch zurück, falls man sich verkalkuliert hat. Da hat man nochmal 54 Millionen, ein bisschen was geht noch in E-Sports. Aber das sind die großen Punkte. Ist euch auch aufgefallen, dass ein wesentlicher Punkt, den ich zumindest in der Diskussion im Frühjahr oft gehört habe, jetzt gar nicht mehr die Rolle spielt, nämlich, Marcus, du hast so Sachen gesagt, wie wir brauchen jetzt erstmal Router im Stadion, wir brauchen erstmal Glasfaser in jedem Stadion, also Infrastrukturmaßnahmen. Das war im Frühjahr, in meinem Eindruck nach, ein viel größeres Thema. Hier steckt das vielleicht irgendwo drin, aber ist gar nicht mehr so der große Posten.
Nee, ist mir jetzt tatsächlich auch die letzten Tage nicht aufgefallen. Ich kriege es also häufig in Dortmund mit, weil ich da bei jedem Heimspiel bin. Da ist einiges gemacht worden Richtung 5G, aber beileibe noch nicht die Erfüllung. Ich denke mal, dass die Liga da sagt, dass das alleine auf die Kappe der Vereine gehen sollen. Aber stimmt schon, das ist jetzt nicht mehr da drin. Vielleicht noch mal eine kurze Bewertung zu diesen Zahlen. Ich kann mir das halt schlecht vorstellen, ob 164 Millionen jetzt für den Aufbau dieser Plattform reicht. Ich glaube, dass sich so eine Liga nur über die großen Vereine rechnet. Das ist ja genauso wie bei Turnieren. Wenn du Heidenheim in die USA schickst, dann musst du halt Heidenheim gegen Bayern spielen lassen. Heidenheim gegen Augsburg, da kannst du logischerweise keinen mit locken. Und 164 Millionen Euro, ist das jetzt viel für die Plattform? Kann man da keine bestehende Plattform schon nutzen? Das sind alles so Fragen. Deshalb wird immer gesagt, es ist alles transparent und für mich bleiben da so viele Fragen offen. Bilder aus der Kabine. Gut, das Vaterunser-Beispiel ist jetzt extrem, aber vielleicht müssen wir das zur Verdeutlichung nochmal sagen. Damit sind jetzt keine Bilder gemeint, wie der Trainer eine Ansprache hält. Dann würde ich sagen, okay, das fände ich auch interessant. Das wäre aber ja auch mit der Dauer oder wird sich ja abnutzen. Aber davon reden wir nicht. Also wir reden von einem Blick in die Kabine, wo dann die Trikots hängen und dann kann der Moderator vielleicht sagen, ja, hier sieht er irgendwie Manuel Neuer heute wieder fit und der spielt, hier hängt sein Trikot und wenn es interessant wird, dann ist die Kamera natürlich schnell raus. Also wie gesagt, mir fehlt da noch jegliches Vorstellungsvermögen, ob das wirklich, darum geht es ja alleine. Das soll für die künftigen Rechtevergaben höhere Erlöse bringen und dass man das Produkt attraktiver macht. Ich glaube, Merkel war es, der hat gestern gesagt, wir werden ein deutlich aufgewertetes Produkt anbieten können. Und da frage ich mich immer noch, womit, also all das, was die jetzt aufzeigen, sehe ich nicht und man muss sich auch mal fragen, wenn es die Liga bei ja nun mehr als einer Milliarde Erlöse pro Saison nicht schafft, eigene Büros in den USA oder was weiß ich wo zu finanzieren oder Auslandsreisen, ja wie schlecht ist denn da gewirtschaftet worden, beziehungsweise wie schlecht ist das Geld verteilt worden, dass die überhaupt in diese Situationen kommen und wenn man dann noch bedenkt, dass die ja, wann hätten die denn ohne Corona anfangen wollen in Digitalisierung zu investieren? Also für mich ist das nach wie vor, hat einfach ganz viele Fragen offen und ich glaube, das habe ich auch heute Morgen noch mal in einem Kommentar geschrieben, dass die Großen sich von den Kleinen mitfinanzieren lassen, was ihnen vor allen Dingen zugute kommt. Jetzt kann man natürlich sagen, klar Bayern München macht halt die Attraktivität aus, auch im Ausland, deshalb sollen die auch mehr bekommen, aber ich weiß, dass das sehr naiv ist, aber warum zahlt Bayern München dann nicht auch den höheren Anteil schon davor, um das zu stemmen, weil jetzt wird es ja auf Elbersberg wie auf Bayern München gleich verteilt, aus diesen 600 Millionen.
TV-Schlüssel ist keine Einbahnstraße, könnte man sagen.
Dafür gibt es jetzt wahrscheinlich bald den Content-Schlüssel. Also es gibt ja schon zumindest Überlegungen darüber, ob man dann, wenn das alles mal aufgebaut ist, dann die Vereine unterschiedlich daran beteiligt, wie viel Content sie dann geliefert haben, wie interessant sie für den internationalen Markt waren. Da hast du es quasi doppelt, also die Kosten tragen jetzt dann alle und dann mögliche Einzelerlöse kommen dann vielleicht sogar wieder nur den zugute, die alle interessieren. Aber das ist bisher noch nur Gedankenspiele, mehr ist es gerade noch nicht. Aber Chaled, ich habe gesehen, du hast ja schon wieder Notizen gemacht, du hast sicher auch noch ganz viele Gedanken zu dieser Verwendung der Mittel.
Ja, also drei Anmerkungen dazu, also zum Ausgangspunkt mit 5G im Stadion und so weiter. Ich meine, das WLAN in den meisten Stadion ist mit denen im ICE zu vergleichen. Also es ist ja nicht existent. Ja, aber ich persönlich finde das ja ganz okay, guckt das Spiel, aber grundsätzlich dieser Ausbau war ja Teil des Infrastruktur-Topfes, der legendäre im Mai, der ja teilweise für Infrastruktur genutzt werden sollte, so kann man das glaube ich sagen. Das ist halt weg, die Zahlungen an die Clubs fallen weg und dann ist halt auch Sache, der Clubs ihr Stadion digital fitter zu machen, sag ich mal. Zu der Plattform, da würde ich gerne sagen, dass man sich mal dieses FIFA Plus mal angucken sollte. Das ist, die FIFA hat so eine Plattform gemacht. Ich glaube, das geht so zumindest grob in die Richtung zu dem, was sich die DFL vielleicht vorstellt. Das Ding mag jetzt erstmal nicht so wichtig sein, für Nutzer in Deutschland zu beginnen. Das wird aber auf Dauer ein Tool sein, um in anderen Ländern was zu erreichen, was Reichweite angeht. Denn wenn du beispielsweise ein Land hast und dort ist das Gebot für die Rechte nicht das, was man sich vorstellt, dann kann man über diese Plattform direkt an die Fans gehen. Heißt auch Direct-to-Consumer. Kann man direkt an die Fans rangehen, die halt um einen Preis bitten. Aber nehmen wir jetzt mal an, Nigeria wurde ja mal als Zielmarkt genannt letztes Jahr oder im Mai. Nehmen wir mal an, in Nigeria der TV-Sender ist nicht bereit, den Preis zu bezahlen. Einen Konkurrenten gibt es nicht. Oder es gibt vielleicht gar keinen Sender, keine Plattform, die das in Nigeria zeigen wollen würde. Dann sagst du halt hier 4,99 Euro im Monat und dann gibt es die Spiele der Bundesliga zu gucken. Das ist ja, also so erreicht man ja. Das hat die FIFA ja mehrfach gemacht. Also, hast du mir das nicht erzählt, die Frauen-WM, genau, das wäre die Rückfalloption gewesen, wenn das in Europa nicht geklappt hätte. Und ich glaube, die Männer-WM wurde, hast du mir das nicht erzählt, in Südamerika doch auch auf FIFA Plus gezeigt.
Ja, ja, genau, genau. Also das gab es jetzt schon mehrfach, ohne dass wir das mitbekommen hätten, weil da muss man halt mit Leuten in anderen Ländern sprechen. Und vor allem, es wurde als Argument auch verwendet. Also die FIFA konnte auch deswegen diesen ganz seltsamen Vergabeprozess rund um die Frauen-WM machen, weil sie immer sagen konnten, gut, wenn wir uns jetzt erst im Mai dazu entschließen, es wird doch nicht in den Öffentlich-Rechtlichen laufen, dann bewerben wir ab dann eben einfach FIFA Plus und dann müssen es die Leute eben streamen.
Genau und diese Plattform, die soll es ja auch, also das wabert immer wieder rum, dass die halt in England das Ding auch richtig voranbringen in dieser Art und so im Ausland ihre Einnahmen noch mal steigern, die ohnehin schon astronomisch sind. Also die verdienen ja allein im Ausland schon das, keine Ahnung, Doppelte, was die Brüder noch mehr als die Bundesliga einnimmt, insgesamt, also international zusammengefasst. Also es ist ja, wenn diese Drohkulisse wahr wird, dann wird die Premier League noch ein größeres finanzielles Monster im europäischen Fußball, als sie ohnehin schon ist. Und die dritte Anmerkung, die ich machen wollte, war zum aufgewerteten Produkt, was Steffen Merkel gesagt hat. Ich glaube, was mit der Kabine, um das auch noch einzuordnen, meint, ist, ich glaube, man kann sich vorstellen, so eine fest installierte Kamera, die beispielsweise die 30 Sekunden zeigt, wenn die in die Kabine gehen. Das ist jetzt nur ein Element von der Aufwertung. Also stell dir vor, der Halbzeit-Fifth kommt und dann sagen die, ja so, gleich geht es weiter bei Sky mit der zweiten Halbzeit. Und in dem Moment gehen die in die Kabine und dann siehst du halt, wie Harry Kane vor Wut den Papierkorb umtritt. Das ist dann natürlich nichts, was 200 Millionen Euro mehr im Jahr wert ist. Aber du hältst halt vom Anspruch der Übertragung halt mit, das Ding unterhaltsam zu halten. Du musst halt mal ein Spiel aus der Premier League mit Deutschland vergleichen. Das ist schon ein Unterschied, wie das aufbereitet wird. Und es geht um Kameraeinstellungen, Perspektiven und so. Also da geht es fast eher ums Schritt halten.
Also was diese OTT-Plattform angeht, also eben die digitale Plattform, mit der man Leute erreicht, die muss her und dass die Kosten dafür bei 164 Millionen liegen, finde ich interessant. Ich kann mir kaum vorstellen, dass der Betrieb über 20 Jahre da auch mit drin ist, weil das ist nämlich der große Kostenfaktor. Denn die Serverkosten sind halt sehr, sehr hoch, weil bei Live-Streaming kannst du nicht buffern. Das heißt, du brauchst eben hohe Serverkosten.
Aber das wurde ja auch so durch die Blume angesprochen, dass das halt, also das ist alles eine Anschubfinanzierung für Dinge. Und den Betrieb, das müssen auch die Clubs leisten, halt die Inhalte dafür liefern und so weiter. Und man darf nicht vergessen, die DFL wird ja fortlaufend weiter finanziert. Es gibt eine Abgabe der Clubs an die DFL. Also wenn jetzt, sagen wir mal, du bist der erste FC Max-Jakob Ost, du bekommst, sagen wir mal, im Jahr 50 Millionen Euro, da musst du einen Teil davon bei der DFL lassen zur Finanzierung der DFL, die dir das Geld für dich bringt. Und diese Abgabe betrug 6,25 Prozent, die wurde nach dem geplatzten Deal im Mai auf 7,75 Prozent angehoben. Und ich habe gestern auch gefragt, wird das jetzt zurückgeschraubt wieder? Weil jetzt ist ja der Deal da, das Geld ist da. Jetzt kann man ja eigentlich die Abgaben der Clubs wieder senken, dass die wieder mehr zur Verfügung haben. Nein, das ist nicht vorgesehen. Es war aber schon vorher klar, dass der Beitrag wieder leicht abgesenkt wird, von 7,75 auf dann 7,50 Prozent. Also das ist jetzt das Vorgehen dahin. Und dieses Geld wird halt auch einen Beitrag dazu leisten, den fortlaufenden Betrieb zu finanzieren.
Ja, trotzdem bin ich sehr gespannt darauf, ob das wirtschaftlich möglich ist. Weil so Livestreaming ist eine teure Angelegenheit und es skaliert nicht so gut. Also man hat immer so den Fehler bei so digitalen Produkten, dass man immer sagt, naja, so Amazon kann halt funktionieren. Wenn du eine Million Bücher im Monat verkaufst, wenn du tausend Bücher im Monat verkaufst, lohnt es sich nicht. Bei Livestreaming ist das nicht so. Es ist extrem schwierig, diese Skalierung technisch hinzubekommen. Warum hat denn Eurosport-Player am ersten Spieltag, als sie damals die Rechte hatten, das nicht hingekriegt? Warum hat es der Sauen früher nicht hinbekommen? Weil es nicht ganz so trivial ist, wie es von außen aussieht. Du musst krasse Serverkapazitäten freimachen und dann geht da richtig Kohle weg. Der Vorteil ist, wenn du international produzierst, dann produzierst du mutmaßlich in Englisch für sehr viele Märkte. Du musst dann nicht mehr den nigerianischen Experten dorthin stellen, das ist dann bei so einer Plattform, können die Leute auch damit leben, die Endverbraucher, wie man es dann nennt, die Abonnenten, wenn es dann quasi einfach auf Englisch produziert wird. Und da hast du quasi eine Produktion, die dann in alle Länder geht. Das ist was, wo du sparst. Aber ansonsten, ich bin gespannt, es konnte mir auch noch keiner genau erklären. Sie haben aber auch noch keine Vorerfahrungen damit, deswegen ist es schwierig zu sagen. Aber ich bin gespannt, wie das mit 4,99 Euro oder 1,99 Dollar, und teurer kannst du es nicht machen. Weil so geil ist die Bundesliga nämlich nicht, dass die Leute dafür mehr zahlen werden. Bin ich gespannt, wie man das finanzieren will, aber wahrscheinlich ist es wichtiger als Hebel gegenüber den nationalen Markten, dann zu sagen, wenn ihr halt nicht bietet, dann werden wir es eben selber streamen und dann kriegen wir es anders verkauft. Also das ist der OTT-Bereich. Und dann waren wir jetzt aber ja schon die ganze Zeit in diesem, ja vielleicht auch sehr emotionalen Bereich, eben der Aufwertung des Produkts. Und da habe ich unterschiedlichste Dinge gehört. Marcus, wahrscheinlich wird das ja dir auch so unter den Nägeln brennen. Ich weiß auch, dass es auch vielen Fans unter den Nägeln brennt. Und ich weiß, dass hier jetzt ein Wort oft folgen wird. Ich spiele es einmal ein. Rote Linien. Rote Linien haben wir unheimlich oft gehört, dieses Wort. Die wurden nämlich eingezogen. Und ich habe in den Vorgesprächen, die ich führen konnte, fiel das schon ganz oft. Also Kabine ist tabu, da haben die Trainer auch gar keine Lust drauf. Mannschaftsbus-Anfahrt ist auch tabu. Vielleicht irgendwie jemand, wenn er aus dem Bus aussteigt, vielleicht jemand voran, Pfiff. Und ich habe mich gefragt, wie soll das denn tatsächlich das Produkt so wirklich aufwerten? Sind das denn die Dinge, die dich zum Beispiel interessieren?
Mich interessieren die nicht, aber da bin ich auch sicherlich die falsche Zielgruppe. Ich bin ja für ganz viele Sachen die völlig falsche Zielgruppe. Ich gucke mir TikTok irgendwie einmal in der Woche an oder so. Da steckt sicherlich viel Geld und viel Potenzial drin. Aber dann müsste ich halt auch wissen, was genau geplant ist. Und dann kann ich sagen, das macht Sinn, das macht attraktiver. Aber ich glaube, die roten Linien, um das jetzt auch mal zu nutzen, damit ist mehr gemeint, wir werden den Spielplan nicht verändern. Wir werden den Investoren nicht mitbestimmen lassen bei neuen Anstoßzeiten. Die es dann sowieso nicht gibt und das ist damit gemeint und da muss ich sagen, deshalb wurde mir das zu häufig betont, weil das war im Mai ja auch schon so. Da hat sich ja nichts geändert. Die haben ja nicht gesagt, also ich habe da keine Veränderungen festgestellt.
Ich glaube, die Änderung ist, da springen wir jetzt so ein bisschen in den Punkten, aber ich glaube, die Änderung ist, dass man sich diesmal schriftlich hat versichern lassen von allen Interessenten am Investoren-Einstieg, dass sie sich an diese roten Linien, die definiert worden halten. Meines Wissens nach gab es das im Frühjahr nicht. Da haben Hellmann und Leckie einfach nur gesagt, es gibt rote Linien und die muss dann auch der Investor einhalten. Aber man hatte eben Beispiele aus anderen Ligen, wo man gesehen hat, naja, also CWC, wenn sie dann erstmal drin sind, haben sie schon irgendwie Lust, da ordentlich mitzusprechen. Und das hat dann Stefan Merkel, glaube ich, zweimal gesagt. Diesmal hat man das schriftlich vorher von allen Interessenten eingeholt, hat das bei der Entscheidungsfindung vorgelegt. Deswegen, ich würde sagen, es gibt da in der Qualität dann doch einen Unterschied. Aber so ganz ist die Frage, ob man sich da wirklich auf das geschriebene Wort verlassen kann. Weil es gibt ja auch andere Art und Weise Druck auszuüben, als eben zu sagen, ihr müsst jetzt Playoffs zum Beispiel einführen, um die Bundesliga toller zu machen. Oder als Beispiel wurde ja das zum Beispiel genannt.
Ganz wichtiger Punkt.
Und die Frage ist ja auch, für wie lange ist das festgeschrieben. Mit Sicherheit nicht für über 20 Jahre, aber wer ist so blöd und schreibt sich für 20 Jahre was fest, was dann vielleicht in fünf Jahren, wo man denkt, wir brauchen aber ein neuer Anschlusszeiten oder einen neuen Wettbewerb. Also ich würde jetzt mal sagen, es gibt zwei Hebel, um ein Produkt attraktiver zu machen, wie die Bundesliga. Das ist einmal ein dauerhaft interessanter Wettbewerb. Das ist natürlich jetzt eine Phase, wo man sagt, der ist doch super spannend. Stuttgart Leverkusen war ein fantastisches Spiel, ohne die Bayern sogar. Alles gut, aber wie gesagt dauerhaft interessant. Und der zweite Hebel ist, du musst deinen Unique Selling Point, Attraktivität, Fankurven und so weiter, das müsstest du eigentlich fordern. Das heißt, ich weiß, dass das hört sich ungerecht vielen Vereinen gegenüber an, die vernünftige und meinetwegen auch gute Arbeit leisten. Aber wenn du einen Schalke statt einen Heidenheim oder einen Hoffenheim in der ersten Liga hättest und diese fanintensiven Vereine, wie sie sich ja selber nennen, fördern würdest, dann hättest du ein deutlich attraktives Produkt. Und das geht nur, indem du das Geld anders verteilst. Und da sind wir, da haben wir ja schon, wie oft haben wir hier zusammengesessen und darüber geredet. Da redet sich, fallet ja auch den Mund fuselig, wenn er um Super League und Financial Fair Play. Es geht nur, also meiner Meinung nach kannst du das Produkt nur attraktiver machen, indem du das Geld anders verteilst. Und deshalb halte ich das alles für sinnvoll, Digitalisierung klar. Aber ich sehe diesen großen Effekt nicht, um zukünftig die deutliche Steigerung an Erlösen hinzubekommen, mit denen du den Verlust ausgleichen willst.
Das müssen ja mehr als acht Prozent muss es ja steigern. Erst dann kommt auch wirklich mehr an.
Genau, in einem immer schwieriger werdenden Markt, was in fünf Jahren ist, weiß man nicht. Aber wir sehen ja derzeit, was in der Welt los ist, in der Politik und in der Wirtschaft. Und das spielt ja alles damit ein. Und deshalb überzeugt mich das, was bislang bekannt ist, noch nicht. Aber vielleicht zaubern die ja auch irgendwas aus dem Hut, was bisher noch gar nicht genannt wird.
Was ein ganz wichtiger Punkt eben war, war der informelle Einfluss. Ich glaube, da muss man mal deutlich machen. Man kann sich viele rote Linien reinschreiben. Aber wenn man halt im Hintergrund Druck macht und sagt, wenn ihr mehr Geld wollt, wenn das klappen soll und wir wollen unsere Rendite, müssen wir das den Leuten verkaufen. Und wir wissen halt auch, dass Geschäftsführer nicht für die Ewigkeit berufen sind. Es kann sein, der Vertrag läuft 20 Jahre, werden wir in 10 oder 15 Jahren noch die beiden selben Geschäftsführer der DFL haben und wird die Nachfolge dann in einigen Jahren, wie auch immer dieser Zeitraum jetzt einzuschätzen sein mag, wird der sich dann so diesen roten Linien verbunden fühlen, wie es jetzt halt Merkel und Lenz für sich betonen.
Braucht man vielleicht nochmal Geld und verkauft dafür dann nochmal ein paar Prozentpunkte, aber wacht dafür eine rote Linie auf.
So, und hängst du einmal in der Nadel, das hat Magdeburg ja im Mai ganz schön formuliert, dann du etablierst ja auch ein System. Willst du jetzt nochmal irgendwelche Prozente verkaufen, dann noch mal eine Anschubfinanzierung für irgendwas anderes ganz Neues, Tolles, in ein paar Jahren brauchst. Aber was ich eben noch sagen wollte, Marcus sprach zwei Hebel an, ein Wettbewerb attraktiver zu machen. Dann sind wir vielleicht noch beim informellen Einfluss. Ich glaube, es gibt noch einen dritten Hebel und das ist weiterhin eine Änderung des Modus. Ich war im September bei der ECA-Generalversammlung in Berlin. Zwei sehr spannende Tage und da hat man, wie formuliere ich das, es gab einen hochrangigen Vertreter eines aus dem deutschen Fußball, ich formuliere es mal so schwammig, wie es geht. Und der sagte zu mir, ja, in Deutschland ist die ganze Medienlandschaft in völliger Aufruhr wegen des DFL-Investors. Hier werden fünf Milliarden verteilt und keiner guckt zu, weil ich war der einzige deutsche Journalist am ersten Tag, der da war. Später kam noch Christoph Biermann von 11 Freunden dazu und Arne Richter von der DPA. Und was für ein Echo dieser DFL-Investor im Verhältnis mit sich bringt. Naja, aber rauf ich hinaus wollte, war, hinterher hat uns Charlie Marschel, das ist der Geschäftsführer der ECA, zum Interview geladen, mich und so zwei, drei andere noch, die da waren. Und die haben mir damals dann die UEFA-Kohle für die kommenden Jahre aufgeteilt. Und da geht es ja um 4,4 Milliarden, die unter den 96 Clubs aufgeteilt werden, die europäisch spielen. Oder dann wird es ein paar mehr sein. Und ich glaube, 104 sind es dann. Und die Nachricht war, es gibt jetzt ein bisschen mehr Geld für die nicht teilnehmenden Clubs. Das ist ja Geld, das eigentlich die Lücke so ein bisschen ausgleichen soll in nationalen Ligen. Aber von unserer Seite war es das jetzt. Die nationalen Ligen müssen ihre Probleme selber lösen. Das machen nicht wir, weil es ist ja das UEFA-Geld, das immer für die Ungerechtigkeit oder die Ungleichheit, ungerecht ist mal ein großes Wort, die Ungleichheit in den nationalen Ligen sorgt. Also wenn die Bayern 90 Millionen von der DFL kriegen, kommen oft halt 120 von der UEFA oben drauf. Dieses Geld ist das Problem. Und der sagte halt, wenn du selber nicht innovativ bist, mit innovativen Malte, Playoffs, dann kannst du auch keinem anderen die Schuld geben, dass es nicht läuft. Guck dir den Modus in der Schweiz an. Der ist jetzt, sind nicht die richtigen Playoffs, aber die haben den Modus geändert, so wie in Schottland. Es gibt dieses System in Belgien. Sehr komplexes System, kann man sagen, glaube ich. Aber da hatten wir einen fantastischen Meisterschaftskampf, zum Beispiel jetzt am Saisonende gesehen letztes Jahr. Und er sagt, von diesen Dingen müssen wir mehr sehen. Und er glaubt, wenn das Produkt gut ist und spannend ist, dann verkauft es sich auch. Und was er damit meint, ist halt, es verkauft sich auch. Er sagt halt, diese Konkurrenzsituation, die sieht er nicht so extrem. Aber diese Konkurrenzsituation, die ist nun mal da und die ist gerade das große Problem der DFL. Es ist immer dieses Business-Deutsche, da sagen die, es gibt ein schwieriges Marktumfeld. Jo, was heißt denn das? Die Premier League zieht das ganze Geld an sich. Die Champions League wird jetzt eine Milliarde mehr bringen. So und bald kommt Gianni mit seiner Club-WM mit 32 Teams, die hervorragend funktionieren wird. Stell dir einen Sommer im Biergarten vor. Dann guckst du da PSG gegen River Plate. Du guckst Barcelona gegen Bayern. Du guckst Real Madrid gegen Palmeiras. Das sind super Spiele, das wird sich ganz toll verkaufen lassen. Und wieder mehr Geld vom TV-Markt nehmen. So und was übrig bleibt, das bleibt halt übrig für die DFL, für die anderen Nationalen liegen, nebenbei gesagt auch für andere Sportarten. Das dürfen wir auch nicht ganz vergessen. So und das ist so unter Druck dieser TV-Markt. Alle wollen das Geld von den gleichen Streaming-Diensten und TV-Sendern. So und die Konkurrenz ist massiv erhöht gerade.
Ja und gleichzeitig, finde ich, wird aber ein Bereich noch ganz grotesk unterbelichtet. Also klar, sportlicher Wettbewerb ist schon mal das erste. Würden wir nur mit Umverteilung der Gelder mit hinbekommen, nicht mal wir drei Idealisten gehen davon aus, dass sich da noch mal irgendwann was verändern wird zum Besseren. Es wird immer so sein, die Großen werden größer und die Kleinen werden keine Chance haben. Aber es gibt ja noch den Teil und dann gibt es quasi das Drumherum-Umspiele. Darüber wird jetzt viel diskutiert, ohne dass man etwas konkreter wüsste. Also dürfen wir mal in die Kabine reingucken. Dürfen wir mal in den Spielertunnel reingucken. Kriegen wir noch ein Interview kurz vor dem Spiel oder in der Halbzeit. Würde ich persönlich sagen, nachrangig. Zeig mir einfach die Einschaltquoten des Vorlaufs von Spielen. Und zwar nicht von Bayern gegen Dortmund, sondern von irgendeinem anderen Spiel. Ich glaube nicht, dass irgendjemand anders da wirklich eine Stunde vorher einschalte, weil ich denke, das schaue ich mir jetzt alles nochmal an. Ich würde sagen, Fußball ist zweimal 45 Minuten plus absurde Nachspielzeiten. Das ist das Kernprodukt. Und das ist nämlich das, worauf ich hinaus will. Ich verstehe nicht, warum immer davon gesprochen wird, das Produkt muss besser werden. Und dann geht man an den einen Hebel nicht ran, nämlich, dass quasi der Wettbewerb besser wird. Okay, wir wissen, warum man da nicht rangeht, aber es ist grotesk. Und der zweite Hebel ist aber die Produktion des Live-Spiels. Und da steht hier schon wieder nichts drin. Ich brauche doch richtig geile Kameraeinstellungen. Ich brauche Splitscreen-Modelle, wo ich meine Zeitlupe zeigen kann, während das laufende Spiel läuft. Weil es ist ein Problem, dass wir immer erst auf eine Spielunterbrechung warten müssen, bis wir noch mal eine Chance sehen können. Ich brauche Live-Grafiken. Ich will vielleicht auch besseres Audio haben. Ich will wissen, was die auf den Trainerbänken schreien, auch wenn die natürlich total eskalieren werden. Corona war das, das war wahrscheinlich auch wieder eine rote Linie. War ganz schlimm, dass wir da alles gehört haben bei den Geisterspielen. Aber dieses Produkt muss verbessert werden. Dieses Produkt ist in manchen Ligen ein bisschen besser, aber den richtig großen Schritt ist da noch keiner gegangen. Du kannst Fußball ganz anders darstellen, als wir es jetzt sehen, wo es das immer gleiche ist, wo Sportscast aber auch wirklich, also sinnbildlich hat Sportscast die Pantoffeln und eine Korthose an. Also traditioneller geht es nicht. Jede Bundesliga-Übertragung ist gleich und sie ist gleich langweilig. Und da musst du auch Kohle rein investieren, weil du brauchst Technik, du brauchst, die Regie wird anders. Du musst auch Dinge probieren, die dann auch mal schiefgehen. Du wirst dann auch mal Einblendungen und so weiter haben, die im Nachhinein nicht funktioniert haben. Aber da steht hier schon wieder gar nichts mit drin. Und das sage ich als jemand, der jedes Bundesligaspiel am Wochenende sieht, bei Männern und bei Frauen. Und über Frauen müssen wir jetzt gar nicht reden. Das ist absolut katastrophal, die Produktion. Aber bleiben wir bei den Männern. Kann ich einfach sagen, wenn ich euch vorher sagen kann, wie die Schnittfolge ist. Mannschaften laufen ein, Schiedsrichter, Mannschaftskreis hier, Mannschaftskreis da, eine große totale, dann Aufstellung, dann gehen wir raus in die Werbung, kommen wieder zurück, Blick auf den Schiedsrichter, Blick in die totale, dann Anpfiff. Wenn ich euch das so sagen kann, und es ist bei jeder fucking Übertragung gleich, dann ist das Grundprodukt schlecht. Und nicht erst drumherum ist das Problem. Und hier will man wieder nicht ran. Und da denke ich mir auch, ja gut, also können sie natürlich machen, aber wird das Problem 0,0 lösen?
Meiner Meinung nach.
Ja, dass es nicht drinsteht, weiß ich nicht, weil da steht schon Innovation TV-Produkte. Das ist in diesem 126-Millionen-Topf. Also weder 126 Millionen, und das ist auch nur ein kleiner Anteil von diesen 126 Millionen, das wird das Problem nicht lösen. Da gebe ich dir vollkommen recht. Ich muss dazu sagen, ich bin aber auch der Kapo der Kamera-1-Ultras. Ich sage Gegennahaufnahmen im Fußball, jederzeit und überall. Ich will das Spiel sehen.
Ich bin für Splitscreens. Ich will die Wiederholung rechts unten sehen und dann kann ich ja entscheiden, wo ich hingucke. Schau dir an, und früher hätte ich auch gesagt, es überfordert einen, aber schau dir die Red Zone an, wo zeitgleich in vier Boxen unterschiedliche Sachen passieren und trotzdem schaffe ich es als Zuschauer da dran zu bleiben. Man gewöhnt sich dran.
Alles nett, aber das Hauptproblem bleibt ja eigentlich der Wettbewerb. Und wie wir beide gesagt haben, der spannende Wettbewerb. Jetzt haben wir jetzt ein, zwei Saisons in Folge einen spannenden Wettbewerb. Jetzt kann man nur hoffen, dass das so bleibt. Ob das so ist, wissen wir nicht. Man muss bei der Geldverteilung auch mal überlegen. Das ist ein ganz gutes Gleichnis gewesen bei der Veranstaltung der Union of European Clubs. Das ist diese Konterorganisation zur ECA für kleinere Clubs. Und da wurde das Fußballfinanzsystem mit dem Klimawandel verglichen. Dieses Bild von der Kappetasse, der Kipppunkt im Klimawandel, dass du die Kappetasse irgendwann so weit über die Tischkante schiebst, dass sie irgendwann runterfällt und kaputt geht und du es halt nicht mehr reparieren kannst. Das gibt es halt auch im Fußball- und im Finanzsystem. Man muss sich halt angucken, was die letzten 15 Jahre passiert ist, was diese UEFA-Kohle in den nationalen Ligen angerichtet hat und so weiter. Und mir sagte halt auch einer im Hintergrundgespräch aus diesem ganzen Fußballbusiness, ja, Herr Nahar, sie arbeiten sich immer an den Einnahmen ab. Glauben Sie mir eins, der Zug ist abgefahren. Es ist zu spät. Es ist zu spät. Wir kriegen es nur noch hin, über Kostenregulierung den Werkbewerb irgendwie zu sichern. Die Unterschiede, wenn du Bochum das Doppelte gibst von dem, was die Bayern kriegen, kriegst du es nicht repariert. Die Unterschiede bei Sponsoren, Tickets, europäischen Einnahmen sind so groß, du kriegst es so nicht repariert. Das ist natürlich auch ein Alibi, natürlich kann man an zwei Schrauben gleichzeitig drehen, das darf man nicht vergessen dabei. Aber die Kostenregulierung, und das hat ja auch Mark Lenz mehrfach in den Mittelpunkt gestellt, jetzt in den letzten Wochen bei Pekas und so, ist Kostenregulierung, muss es sein. Du brauchst diesen sogenannten Salary Cap auf europäischer Ebene. Es ist halt ganz schwer, eine Zahl zu finden, die für Manchester City und ZSKA Sofia gleichzeitig gilt. Aber das ist halt, das wird das Thema der nächsten Jahre sein. Das muss einfach her, auch im Bereich dann mit Multiclub Ownership. Da sind so viele Herausforderungen gerade. Es wird schwer.
Vielleicht könnten wir da, wir waren ja eigentlich bei dem Fokussierung des Kapitals auf die DFL. Das war quasi die erste Kernänderung. Ich glaube, das haben wir ganz gut jetzt besprochen. Diskutieren könnte man da noch viel mehr, aber wir wissen jetzt so grob, wo das Geld hingeht. Ich freue mich auf die Legenden, die dann in Japan antreten. Also ich würde Jürgen Kohler in Tokio, ich würde es mir nicht angucken, aber lustig, wenn ich es tatsächlich dann doch. Ich glaube, wir landen jetzt aber dann damit beim dritten Punkt, nämlich bei der Transparenz gegenüber Clubs, gegenüber den Bietern, gegenüber der Öffentlichkeit und auch letztlich beim Entscheidungsprozess, der jetzt dazu geführt hat, dass es jetzt eben dann doch mit dieser 66,66% Mehrheit zu dem Einstieg des Investors gekommen ist. Weil ich glaube, Marcus, da müssen wir nämlich auf die Ausgaben gucken, weil ich sehr oft gehört habe, dass es eine ganze Reihe von Clubs gibt, die gar nicht anders hätten stimmen können, weil sie solche Kostenprobleme haben. Ist das vielleicht eigentlich ein Kern dieser Debatte, der aber ein bisschen untergeht, weil wir ja wirklich immer viel über Einnahmen sprechen, aber weniger über Ausgaben?
Ja, das fängt ja eigentlich schon früher an, weil die viel diskutierte und von Freiburg ins Spiel jetzt beim aktuellen Prozess ins Spiel gebrachte Binnenfinanzierung, die scheitert ja vor allen Dingen daran, dass viele Vereine sich das einfach nicht erlauben können, auf ein wenig drei Millionen Euro im Jahr zu verzichten. Das wäre jetzt für Bayern und Dortmund und ein paar Werksclubs wäre das einfach, aber sie können es halt nicht. Und wenn du fremd finanzierst, musst du das natürlich besichern. Und das können sie auch nicht, weil sie die Medienrechte, oder die Erlöse aus den Medienrechten schon verwendet haben. Das heißt, die Ausgabenseite verhindert vieles, weil halt viel zu viel Geld, wenn man im europäischen Vergleich guckt, das ist ein valides Argument, ist das noch ein ziemlich gesundes Verhältnis, vergleichsweise in der Bundesliga, aber es ist halt trotzdem zu viel Geld. Guckt ihr die Gehaltszettel, die Bayern-Zahlen sind ja letztlich rausgekommen, die haben jetzt Personalkosten für den Lizenzbereich von, glaube ich, mehr als 300 Millionen Euro. Da kannst du schon sehr, sehr viel von machen und da kannst du, wenn du davon 10 Prozent abgibst, hättest du sehr viel, um Büros in Singapur und so weiter zu unterrichten. Die Vereine sind halt nicht bereit, da die Ausgaben so zu drehen, dass sie in Innovation gesteckt wird, sondern es wird halt auf Gedei und Verderb versucht, die sportliche Qualität zu stärken. Teilweise natürlich auch verständlich, das ist ja dieses berühmte Rattenrennen. Die Unterschiede zwischen 2. Liga und 3. Liga sind viel zu groß. Es ist eine Katastrophe, wenn du als Verein, wie aktuell wäre es, Borussia Dortmund, die Beispiele VfB, Stuttgart, HSV, Werder, Bremen, Schalke zeigen es, was passiert, wenn du dauerhaft oder wenn du häufiger in der Champions League gespielt hast und dann plötzlich nicht mehr dabei bist, dann gehst du kaputt. Das ist nur teilweise Schuld der Vereine. Das ist einfach ein Fehler im System. Und insofern hast du jetzt quasi, zumindest hat die DFL es so verkauft, nur eine Möglichkeit gehabt, dieses Kapital einzusammeln und das ist über dieses Investorenmodell und wir haben gestern noch jemanden gesprochen, der sagte, also mir fehlt einfach die Alternative. Ach ja, das war ja der Stefan Hoffmann, der hat das ja offen gesagt, wir haben mit Ja gestimmt, aber auch nicht aus vollster Überzeugung, weil das Modell war für uns die beste Alternative. Er sagte, vielleicht hätte man andere Modelle noch mal genauer durchrechnen können, Fremdfinanzierung und so weiter, aber er hat natürlich auch oder Mainz hat auch den Zeitdruck gesehen, der da drauf war, weil das geht ja jetzt rasend schnell, wir reden von Ausschreibung Medienrechte Januar, wir reden von Investorabschluss März, Ende erstes Quartal und Vergabe der Medienrechte im zweiten Quartal, also wenn man mal sieht, was da auf dem Spiel steht, es sind da schon sehr sehr kurze Zeiträume, in der das alles ausverhandelt werden muss.
Und du hast eine schlechte Verhandlungsposition auch gegenüber den Interessenten, weil die wissen das ja auch.
Genau, dieser Riesendruck ist halt da drauf, weil viele Vereine absolut am Limit leben. Wenn man mal bedenkt, müssen wir nochmal zu Beginn Corona, Christian Seif hat, der hat gesagt, 13 von 36 Clubs stehen vor der Insolvenz. Und der einzige Club, der da in diese geregelte Corona-Insolvenz, nenne ich es jetzt mal vereinfacht gegangen, das war der erste FC Kaiserslautern und alle Clubs von damals gibt es noch. Aber die sind natürlich auch nicht reich geworden.
Ich glaube, da sind wir fast wieder beim Thema Demut. Der Betrag ist ja eigentlich egal, der in die Bundesliga und die zweite Bundesliga fließt. Du wirst immer, also Rattenrennen ist natürlich das böse Wort dazu, aber du wirst immer erleben, es war ja dann auch oft angemerkt, es muss jetzt mehr Rücklagen geben für die nächste Pandemie und nachhaltiger, das alles, Wirtschaften und so weiter. Das wird es natürlich niemals geben. Das kann es auch gar nicht geben. Stell dir vor, du sitzt in der Geschäftsstelle und bist auf Platz 15. So, was machst du? Lege ich jetzt die 5 Millionen Euro, die ich übrig habe, auf dem Nachhaltigkeitsstapel im Keller für die nächste Corona-Pandemie oder hole ich Simon T. Rodde, der mich da unten rausballert? Natürlich hole ich Simon T. Rodde, weil Absteigen ist mit Zweifel teurer. Das wird immer so weitergehen.
Ja, gleichzeitig, also ich bin da hellhörig geworden an einer Stelle, an der Steffen Merkel etwas gesagt hat. Das habe ich vorhin schon angeteasert. Wir hören es uns mal kurz an und dann erkläre ich kurz, warum ich glaube, dass diese beiden Punkte zusammenhängen.
Zudem, wenn ich das vielleicht noch ergänzen darf, hatten wir auch in Clubgesprächen teilweise das Gefühl, dass es durchaus den einen oder anderen Club gibt, der natürlich nach intensiver Befassung eine positive Tendenz hatte, ehrlicherweise dann aber auch auf Clubbegebenheiten inklusive der Gremien natürlich innerhalb der letzten Tage und Wochen auch eine gewisse Dynamik reinkam und möglicherweise die eine oder andere Zustimmung, mit der wir auf Basis der Fakten gerechnet hatten, sich dann aber auch so nicht im Endergebnis wiederfindet, weil es entsprechend auch eine umfassende Befassung richtigerweise mit den Gremien innerhalb der Clubs gab.
Also man muss das so ein bisschen aus den paar Prinzipien wieder runterkochen, worum geht es hier, er hat letztlich gesagt, dieses Ergebnis pro Investor wäre seiner Einschätzung nach deutlicher ausgefallen, wenn manche Clubs, die Mitglieder geführt sind und Gremien haben, so hätten stimmen können, wie sie gerne gestimmt hätten wollen, es aber nicht durften, weil sie gegenüber ihren Gremien und auch ihren Fans, die ja mehrheitlich den Investoreneinstieg ablehnen, das Gesicht nicht verlieren wollen. Und ich glaube, das ist deswegen, das ist für sich genommen schon eine interessante Aussage. Ich finde, es hängt aber auch zusammen mit eben den Ausgaben der Clubs, denn wenn wir darüber reden, dass es eine umfassende Transparenz gegenüber Clubs, Beatern und Öffentlichkeit gegeben hätte, dann würde ich sagen, also gegenüber Fans und Öffentlichkeit nein und gegenüber uns Medien, wie viel wir telefonieren mussten, also ihr ja noch viel mehr als ich, um Informationen zu bekommen, würde ich nicht als transparent bezeichnen. Ich glaube aber, es gibt einen Grund und der Grund ist, die Clubs müssten eigentlich ihren Fans gegenüber, manche Clubs müssten zugeben, ey, wir haben nicht mal 3 Millionen Euro in der Saison und wir haben übrigens unsere zukünftigen Einnahmen, die sind schon verpfändet. Wir können da jetzt gar nicht sagen, wir schichten das noch um und im Personaletat kommen wir auch nicht mehr wirklich gerade runter, weil dann schwimmt uns hier alles weg. Ist das vielleicht die bittere Wahrheit, Chaled, die erklärt, warum auch die Gespräche, die man mit Clubvertretern hat, sich immer so entscheiden zwischen intern und extern. Extern habe ich schon viele Leute auch poltern hören über Probleme im Fußball und intern wird einem dann gesagt, wir haben keine Kohle, wir sind so klamm, es steht wirklich spitz auf Knopf und keine Ahnung, wie das gehen soll. Wenn jetzt nicht die Einnahmen steigern, dann haben wir ein richtiges Problem.
Ja, das hatten wir im Grunde gerade eben. Das ist natürlich das Hauptproblem. Es ist halt immer zu wenig Geld da im Fußball, obwohl eigentlich viel zu viel Geld drinsteckt im Umkehrschluss. Der O-Ton, das war Mark Lenz, nicht Steffen Merkel übrigens, der, was er da gesagt hat, ist natürlich total interessant, weil du musst ja auch angucken, gerade was Markus angesprochen hat, Stefan Hoffmann, muss man auch sagen, der ist von Mainz 05. Ich glaube, das haben wir gerade eben nicht zugeordnet. Die Motive Ja zu sagen und die Motive Nein zu sagen, sind sehr, sehr unterschiedlich. Also Freiburg sagt, das schaffen wir ohne Investor, das zu bezahlen. Warum sollen wir an Dritten beteiligen? Die Kölner sagen, wir Fremdkapital, das ist eine bessere, eine billigere Idee. Und Union Berlin sagt, wir wollen aber Kohle für uns haben und nicht für die Liga. Also das sind so unterschiedliche Motive bei gewesen. Und was dann die innenpolitische Sicht der Clubs angeht, die du angesprochen hast und die Mark Lenz eben angesprochen hat mit den Gremien, das ist total interessant. Also bei Düsseldorf haben ja Alexander Jobst und auch Klaus Alofs eigentlich durchblicken lassen, dass sie im Grunde dafür wären, also durch das Jahr stimmen wollten. Dann haben die aber natürlich so eine nervige Mitgliederversammlung gehabt, die denen gesagt hat, nee, das wollen wir nicht. Und 50 plus 1 wird natürlich als das große Kulturgut vor sich hergetragen, wenn es nützlich ist in der Bundesliga. Aber 50 plus 1 heißt ja noch 50 plus 1. Also die Mitglieder sind das Wichtigste, das höchste Gremium eigentlich. Die bestimmen, wo es langgeht. Wenn wir Mitglieder geführte Clubs haben, haben wir Mitglieder geführte Clubs. Das heißt auf der anderen Seite natürlich nicht, dass sie jeden Linksverteidiger zur Abstimmung stellen müssen. Das ist ja auch richtig so. Aber solche entscheidenden strategischen Fragen, ich finde, da bedarf es eigentlich schon einer Beteiligung der Mitglieder. Und das ist ja auch ein Punkt gewesen bei Osnabrück. Die haben gesagt, die Mitglieder werden nicht beteiligt, deswegen enthalten wir uns. Das geht mit unserem Selbstverständnis nicht zusammen. Und es ist natürlich in einer gewissen Art und Weise wäre es ja auch unverschämt, sich über so ein Mitgliedervotum hinwegzusetzen. Ich meine, Magdeburg hatte 88, irgendwas Prozent Nein. St. Pauli hatte 93 Prozent, glaube ich, Nein. Bei Düsseldorf waren es irgendwas über 70. Bei Augsburg, das war fast nirgendwo zu lesen, gab es zwar nur 56 Prozent Nein, aber eine hohe Zahl an Enthaltungen und wenig Gegenstimmen. Also, oder dafür stimmen. Und so ein Votum muss man, wenn man sagt, wir sind 50 plus 1, und man sagt dann immer, ja, es ist toll, 50 plus 1, Mitglieder geführt selbstbestimmter Fußball in Deutschland.
Was ja auch Lenz und Merkel sagen. Ja, also Lenz und Merkel sagen, sie sind die größten Verfechter von 50 plus 1.
Ja, ja, aber es passt dann immer nur, wenn es gerade passt, ne?
Ja gut, aber wenn es dann diese Voten gibt der Mitglieder, dann sagen ja die Vertreter, das hat man auch durchgehört auf der Pressekonferenz. Dann, wenn sie darauf angesprochen werden, ja die Fans sind ja dagegen, was ja so ist, dann wird immer durch die Blume gesagt, ja die haben ja keine Ahnung. Und gleichzeitig wird aber gesagt, Kernänderung zum Frühjahr war, wir sind so viel transparenter. Also was stimmt denn jetzt? Entweder wissen die Fans die eigentliche Wahrheit nicht, dann wart ihr nicht transparent, dann stimmt das nicht. Oder sind die Fans zu dumm es zu erkennen, dann habt ihr aber gerade eine ziemlich harte Aussage gegenüber Fans getroffen.
Ich glaube, du hast halt, wenn du in der Mitgliederversammlung bei den klassischen Traditionsclubs gehst und du erwähnst das böse I-Wort, dann ist sowieso Ende, dann verlierst du jede Abstimmung, ist auch klar. Aber es ist halt, wenn du sagst, Mitgliedergeführt, also nochmal, es ist der Souverän dieser Clubs. Sie haben das Sagen, das wird immer wieder betont. Und hier ist es nicht der Fall, das muss man ganz klar sagen. Und es ist so eine wichtige strategische Entscheidung. Wie gesagt, man muss nicht jeder Entscheidung den Mitgliedern vorlegen. Das ist ja auch gar nicht, auch in den Clubs gar nicht gewollt. Das würden die Mitglieder auch gar nicht erwarten. Es gibt dann so eine Beteiligung von gewählten Vertretern, die dann beispielsweise bei hohen Transfersummen dann schon mal zustimmen müssen und so. Ist ja auch okay. Aber bei so einer Entscheidung dann zu sagen, das machen wir jetzt innerhalb von einem Vierteljahr, setzen wir diesen ganzen Prozess neu auf. Und da ist ja auch gar nicht die Zeit. 36 oder wen müssen wir abziehen? Leverkusen, Wolfsburg, also diese ganzen. Und gut, eine Mitgliederversammlung in Leipzig wäre in der Kürze der Zeit immer zu organisieren, aber woanders halt nicht. Das ist halt keine Mitgliederbeteiligung. Das muss man ganz klar sagen.
Genau. Und dann kann man nicht sagen, man ist 50 plus 1 Verfechter und das dann aber auf der anderen Seite so durchziehen, weil ganz viele der Informationen, die ja auch Mitglieder gebräucht hätten für ein Votum, die haben wir jetzt gerade erst genannt. Also wie zum Beispiel die Kosten verteilt werden, was eigentlich mit der Kohle angefangen werden soll. Das bringt uns eigentlich zu so einem ganz entscheidenden Punkt, Marcus. Die Fans, die organisierten Fans lehnen den Investoreneinstieg ab. Die Clubs haben sich mit der knappest allmöglichen Mehrheit dafür jetzt entschieden. Es scheint so zu sein, dass diese Frontlinie, die es gibt zwischen den Ultra-Szenen und den Club-Vertretern und auch Verbandsvertretern und Liga-Vertretern, der Graben, er wird immer tiefer und vielleicht wird er irgendwann nicht mehr zugeschüttet werden können. Oder bin ich dazu dramatisch?
Nee, glaube ich nicht, wobei ich das gar nicht auf die Ultras beschränken würde. Also ich war beispielsweise letztens auf der Mitgliederversammlung von Borussia Dortmund. Da hat ein Fan, der kein Ultra ist, ich glaube noch nicht mal in der aktiven Szene, der hat da referiert und es gab ja auch die Versammlung in Dortmund im Mai mit Watzke und Hellmann, jetzt mit Watzke und Lenz und da haben Fans Argumente vorgetragen, denen ich größtenteils folgen kann. Das Hauptargument ist, ein Investor will wissen, was mit seinem Geld passiert und will das in die Richtung lenken, dass er eine möglichst hohe Rendite hat. Und dieses Argument kann ja niemand ausräumen, indem er sagt, wir werden keinen Spielplan verändern. Von daher glaube ich, dass das schwer zu kicken sein wird, wobei ich jetzt tatsächlich sehe, dass die Fanszenen mit Blick auf das, was die Polizei sich in den vergangenen Wochen und Monaten erlaubt hat, einen vorm größeren Problem stehen werden und das wahrscheinlich mehr Aufmerksamkeit noch generieren wird, wahrscheinlich auch zu Recht. Nichtsdestotrotz bleiben die sehr kritisch und werden diesen ganzen Prozess auch weiterhin sehr kritisch begleiten, denn die wollen ja genau wie wir wissen, wer kommt da rein, wo er hat er das Geld, wofür nutzt er das Geld, denn wir sind bei einem, noch mal ein kleiner Ausflug, auch Richtung Transparenz. Das ist ja alles richtig, was die DFL sagt, dass die Mehrheit immer bei den Clubs liegen wird. Das war auch im Mai so, aber wir hatten das Papier ja vorliegen. Im Beirat dieser Tochtergesellschaft hätten von sieben Mitgliedern zwei vom Investor gesessen und die hätten ein Vetorecht, also zwei von sieben, klar, es ist die Minderheit, aber ein Vetorecht in, ich zitiere, bei besonders wichtigen Entscheidungen, damit machen die halt alles kaputt. Also klar kannst du sagen, die können nicht aktiv entscheiden, die können aber sagen, nee, so machen wir es halt nicht. Und auf diese Frage, ob ein Investor über ein Beirat oder wie immer du das Gremium nennst, es wurden ja Begriffe so ein bisschen verschoben, strategische Vermarktungspartnership, ist egal, ob das ein Beirat ist oder ein Wirtschaftsrat oder wie auch immer. Gibt es dieses Vetorecht noch? Diese Frage hat bis heute niemand beantwortet. Und wenn es das Vetorecht gibt, dann stehen wir da, wo wir im Mai auch gestanden haben und dann sieht das plötzlich schon wieder ganz anders aus.
Und müssen wir nicht eigentlich davon ausgehen, dass es dieses Vetorecht gibt, Chaled? Ich weiß nicht, wie tief du jetzt in der Venture-Capital-Welt drin bist, aber alles, was mir zugespielt wurde, war natürlich wollen die dann mitreden, natürlich sichern die sich Einfluss über ganz, ganz viele andere Wege als über solche Satzungen oder dann eben, das sind ja dann Gesellschaftsverträge, die da dann aufgesetzt werden bei so einer Mediaco.
Ja, ich glaube, einen Teil des Vetorechts haben sie benannt. Sie sagen ja, wenn quasi, also sie müssen halt die ganz grundlegenden Regeln einer Partnerschaft vereinbaren und dazu gehört halt natürlich, dass die DFL nicht einseitig diesen Vertrag kündigen kann, wenn der Partner das nicht will. Also der Partner hätte dann vor allem ein Vetorecht dagegen, das ganze Ding einseitig zu beenden, also damit die halt auch Sicherheit haben, dass dieser Vertrag erfüllt wird. Die spannende Frage ist halt, ob das alles ist.
Da sind wir ja wieder bei der Transparenz, man weiß es nicht.
Ich glaube, ein Vetorecht wird es auf dem Papier vielleicht weniger geben, aber es gab im Handelsblatt, in der Fußballszene eine verschmähte Zeitung, aber es ist sehr interessant gewesen zum Thema Investor. Und da haben die den Deutschlandchef von, so hieß es, einer prozessbeteiligten Private Equity-Firma gesprochen und der sagt, Mitgestaltung, Mitbestimmung, das ist das A und O. Und das klingt wie eine klar formulierte Drohung für mich. Also das ist natürlich eine ganz klare Sache, dass die Einfluss nehmen wollen. Und das muss jetzt in den Verhandlungen und dann vor allem auch im Betrieb sich erstmal darstellen, wie man Einfluss nehmen kann. Und da sind wir eigentlich wieder beim Thema von vorhin informeller Einfluss, wenn es über die beiden Beiräte nicht geht, wenn es über das Veto-Recht nicht geht. Man wird da irgendwie im Hintergrund immer Druck ausüben können. Weil wenn sie jetzt kein Veto-Recht haben, sagen wir mal, es gibt ja 50 plus 1. Klaus Michael Kühne beim Hamburger SV hat offiziell auch kein Veto-Recht. Natürlich hat er das alleinige Veto-Recht, weil er die Rechnungen bezahlt. Das ist ja der ganz entscheidende Punkt dabei. Wer die Musik bestellt, dann ist klar, wie es läuft. Und das werden wir halt erst im Laufe der Zeit sehen. Was ich noch ganz interessant fand, auch bei der Pressekonferenz und bei diesem kilometerlangen FAQ, das die DFL veröffentlicht hatte, was ich übrigens komplett gelesen habe, schöne Grüße an den, der es geschrieben hat, da war ein Vergleich gezogen worden, ein schrecklicher Satz, da wurde ein Vergleich gezogen mit diesen Vermarktungspartnerschaften der Clubs, hat er auch in der Pressekonferenz gestern noch mal angerissen, diese Sport 5, In-Front, IMG-Deals, dass das ja gar nichts Ungewöhnliches sei im Grunde, was die DFL machen, sei dasselbe.
Eine Elust-Beteiligung.
Ja, was die Clubs schon mal gemacht haben. Also und lässt man so ein bisschen außer Acht, dass diese Deals auch in den Clubs oft aus einer wirtschaftlichen Not heraus geboren wurden. Ich gucke nach Dortmund, zu Markus, ich glaube, der kann uns da was zu erzählen gleich, wie das in Dortmund gelaufen ist. Man weiß von vielen Clubs, dass die Personal dadurch gewonnen haben. Ja, es entstehen ein paar Vorteile und auch, ja, wie man so sagt, Know-how und so weiter. Aber tatsächlich müssen viele auch nach Ende dieser Partnerschaften immer noch Provisionen abdrücken, wenn es immer noch derselbe Trikotsponsor ist, den der Laden dann da bereitgestellt hat. Das ist keine Einbahnstraße, da geht viel Geld verloren bei, ne?
Ja, also wer zu den Vermarktern und ihrem Einfluss auf den deutschen Fußball was wissen will, das habe ich in einer Elf-Lebenfolge mal aufgearbeitet. Das ging alles Mitte der 90er los, Anfang der 90er und wirkt bis heute rein. Also diesen Vergleich habe ich auch wahrgenommen und fand ihn auch mutig. Ich dachte mir, das klappt nur bei Leuten, die jetzt mit Vermarktungsagenturen sich noch nicht so viel beschäftigt haben, die da jetzt nicht aufstrahlen. Ich habe noch einen O-Ton zur Reaktion der Fans und dann könnten wir nämlich vielleicht auch, Marcus, du das dann gerne mal anfangen, überleiten zum Abstimmungsverhalten der Vereine. Was wissen wir, wer wie gestimmt hat und warum ist der Fall Hannover 96 mal wieder so besonders? Aber hören wir noch mal kurz, was Sie zu den Fans und ihrer Ablehnung gesagt haben.
Zum Thema der Äußerung seitens der Fans jetzt auch an den letzten Spieltagen, das haben wir natürlich vernommen. Aus unserer Sicht ist wichtig und das hat Mark Lenz auch eingangs gesagt, dass wir jetzt mit diesem Verhandlungsmandat auch vor diesem Hintergrund sehr vertrauensvoll im Sinne der Liga, im Sinne aller Leute, die diese Liga und diesen Klubs auch verpflichtet sind und die diese Klubs auch lieben, sehr vertrauensvoll erst mal natürlich umgehen werden.
Reicht dir das an Versicherung von Steffen Merkel, Markus?
Ja, das heißt ja alles und gar nichts. Wir vertrauensvoll umgehen, also dass wir die Fans nicht beruhigen. Warum auch? Es ist halt vage. Das ist ja auch okay und du kannst ja auch über Verträge, die noch verhandelt werden müssen, kannst du halt nicht im Detail was sagen. Aber ja, ich sag's mal. Beim Fall Hannover 96 sind wir ja da. Hier scheint, wir kennen das Abstimmungsverhalten von Martin Kind nicht. Ich habe jemandem gesprochen, der gesagt hat, der ist sich sehr, sehr sicher, dass Martin Kind mit Ja gestimmt hat. Aber um das mal nicht von mir zizieren zu müssen, mache ich mal eben eine WhatsApp auf. Ich habe nämlich heute Morgen mit dem Holger Jakob. Schöne Grüße soll ich von dem bespielen.
Sehr schöne Grüße, Ed Sportanwalt.
Genau, das ist ein Fachanwalt für Sportrecht aus Berlin. Ich muss mich jetzt noch mal ein bisschen ausholen, ich hatte ja gestern in der PK auch die Frage gestellt. Also Martin Kind hat die Weisung gekriegt, das EV mit Nein zu stimmen. Die DFL hat offiziell festgestellt, der EV ist Weisungsbefugt gegenüber Martin Kind. Das heißt vereinfacht, er hätte mit Nein stimmen müssen. Nun hat die DFL aber auch, und das haben auch andere gesagt, die argumentieren, diese Weisungsbefugnis gilt nur im Binnenverhältnis des Vereins Hannover 96. Wenn er den Verein nach außen, also bei der DFL, vertritt, gilt das nicht. Habe ich ehrlich gesagt nicht verstanden, deshalb habe ich den Holger Jakob gefragt, und ich gucke es mir mal an.
Man muss dazu sagen, wenn du jetzt das Zitat raussuchst, man muss dazu sagen, die Wahl, sie wurde eben geheim in einer Urne und schriftlich, also auch nicht digital durchgeführt. Also sprich, es wurde auch alles dafür getan, dass wir, nochmal Stichwort Transparenz, wir müssen jetzt im Nachhinein rausfinden, wie wer gestimmt hat. Es ist nicht öffentlich einsehbar, also da war überhaupt nicht transparent.
Entschuldigung, ein Einwurf dazu, daran siehst du auch, was für ein Misstrauen da herrscht. Also die haben die Wahlzettel beantragt und die geheime Abstimmung beantragt. Also die geheime Abstimmung ist dazu da, dass keiner sieht, was sie machen. Die Zettel sind dazu da, dass aber auch intern keiner sieht, was sie machen. Die haben Angst davor, in einer elektronischen Abstimmung nachverfolgbar zu sein. Wer Ja und Nein gestimmt hat, weil sie halt vor sportpolitischen Konsequenzen Sorge haben. Das ist die Atmosphäre da, das muss man sich schon mal vergegwärtigen.
Wir haben extra eine Ohne mitgebracht zu dieser Mitgliederversammlung. Und wer weiß, vielleicht ist da für Hannover 96 sogar einer der Hauptgründe, denn du hast jetzt ja sicher das Zitat, das könnte ja auch sportpolitisch oder sportjuristisch eigentlich Konsequenzen haben eventuell.
Genau, also ich habe ihn gefragt, ist diese Argumentation, Weisungsbefugnis Hannover 96 gilt nur nach innen stichhaltig. Und dann schreibt er, normalerweise ist das so, in Klammern, zum Schutz des geschäftlichen Verkehrs. Das ist wahrscheinlich dann wieder sowas juristisches. Und dann in diesem Fall kannte der, Zitat, geschäftliche Verkehr allerdings den Vereinswillen. Und gerade vor dem Hintergrund von 50 plus 1 kann es dann nicht richtig sein, dass eine gegenteilige Stimme, die auch noch entscheidend für den Ausgang der Beschlussfassung ist, gilt. So, dann habe ich ihm Danke geschrieben und dann hat er was geschrieben, was ich kapiere. Also auf den ersten Blick. Das Abstimmungsergebnis mit der entscheidenden Ja-Stimme von Kind für den Verein Hannover 96 darf nicht stehen, sofern 50 plus 1 noch irgendeinen Wert haben soll. Damit können wir arbeiten. Deshalb finde ich, muss die Öffentlichkeit, vor allem müssen die Mitglieder von Hannover 96 zwingend erfahren, wie Martin Kind abgestimmt hat. Das Problem ist, dass er sagen kann, was er will.
Aber kriegen wir vielleicht die 35 anderen Abstimmungsergebnisse raus und können es dann nach dem Ausschluss verfügen?
Also wir haben ja schon neun Nein-Stimmen. Wer ist die zehnte Nein-Stimme? Das ist die Frage.
Aber dann wäre auch die Frage, ob Martin Kind nicht sagen kann, wer sagt euch denn, dass Nürnberg und Braunschweig die Wahrheit sagen?
Ja, natürlich.
Also du wirst ihn glaube ich juristisch nicht dahin kriegen. Also wir werden es am Ende nicht wissen. Wir werden es nicht erfahren.
Könnt ihr kurz das Abstimmungsverhalten nennen, weil ich denke, dass die Hörerinnen und Hörer sich vor allem fragen, wie hat mein Verein gestimmt?
Ja, ich würde noch mal ganz kurz zu 50 plus 1 sagen. Wir haben gestern häufig oder viele Leute gefragt, ja war das denn überhaupt kein Thema oder wie kam das denn zur Sprache mit 50 plus 1 und so. Und dann sagten die, das war kein Thema und die häufigste Begründung war, weil es noch keine abschließende Kartellrechtliche Beurteilung gibt. Also zu diesen Ausnahmefällen Wolfsburg, Wolfsburg-Lewakosen.
Der Hoffnheim ist dieser Befangenheitsantrag von, hat die nicht Ismail gestellt? Also dieser Befangenheitsantrag, der läuft dann auch, der hält das Ganze so ein bisschen auf. Im Grunde waren sich ja einig, da gibt es ja diese Luxussteuer für Lewakosen und Wolfsburg, also die können ganz zufrieden sein, wie das gelaufen ist.
Ablassante würde ich es nennen.
Also kurzum zu Hannover 96, das bleibt auf jeden Fall Thema, da wird von dem Verein auch was kommen, das habe ich gehört, also vom Mutterverein jetzt. Und da Chaled, der fleißigere von uns beiden ist, referiert er jetzt das Abstimmungsverhältnis.
Ich bin wieder für die Drecksarbeit da. Gut, gehen wir los, also und fangen wir an, nein, ja, Enthaltung, was wollt ihr zuerst?
Sag uns mal erst das ja, dann die Enthaltung und dann zum richtig juicy, dann kommen wir zu den nein Stimmen.
Also ja haben gesagt und diese Information beruht entweder auf eigenen Mitteilungen der Clubs, auf Interviews und es gab im Kicker eine Umfrage dazu bei den Clubs. Also legen wir mal los, Bayern München, Leipzig, Hoffenheim, Bayer Leverkusen, 1. FC Heidenheim, VfL Wolfsburg, Borussia Dortmund, Werder Bremen, Eintracht Frankfurt, Borussia Mönchengladbach, VfB Stuttgart, VfL Bochum, Mainz 05, Darmstadt 98, Karlsruhe SC, Hamburger SV, SC Paderborn, Spielvereinigung, Greuther Fürth und Schalke 04. Das ist die Zustimmungsseite, die wir bislang öffentlich haben.
Lass uns kurz noch mal sagen, was wir wissen, wer seine Meinung geändert hat im Vergleich zu Mai. Das ist Karlsruhe SC, was ich auf jeden Fall weiß. Karlsruhe SC, VfB Stuttgart und Schalke 04. Gibt es da noch einen weiteren?
Das ist meines Erachtens die Wählerwanderung, die wir wissen. Es wird mir auf den ersten Blick keine Ausreißer zum letzten Mal einfallen. Was hat denn Mainz letztes Mal gemacht? Ich weiß es nicht.
Die müsste man nachgucken, aber damals haben wir das ja auch. Also die drei auf jeden Fall, Stuttgart, Schalke und Karlsruhe haben ihre Meinung geändert.
Gut, dann kommen wir zur Enthaltung und nochmal die Betonung. Enthaltung hat die gleiche Wirkung wie Nein, weil es die Zahl der Ja-Stimmen war, die zum Ziel geführt hat für die DFL. Das war der VfL Osnabrück, die wie gesagt mit der Begründung fehlende Mitgliederbestimmung und auch ein Argument angeführt haben, was von den Gegnern kam, dass durch die Stärkung der internationalen Vermarktung auch dadurch wieder mehr Geld in die Spitze fließt, weil die internationale Vermarktung noch mal deutlicher zugunsten der großen Clubs läuft als die nationale Vermarktung. Kommen wir zu den Nein-Stimmen. Erster FC Köln, Erster FC Union Berlin ist zu vermuten, da ging nicht so komplett das Abstimmungsverhalten raus aus der Mitteilung, aber es wirkte klar nach Ablehnung. SC Freiburg, FC St. Pauli, Fortuna, Düsseldorf, Hertha BSC, Erster FC Nürnberg, Eintracht Braunschweig und Erster FC Magdeburg. Das sind die Nein-Stimmen. Da kann man auch mal drauf kommen, dass diese Nein-Stimmen, haben wir eben schon gesagt, sehr heterogen die Begründung. Die Unklarheit haben wir bei Hannover 96 ja eben schon besprochen. Und fehlende öffentliche Positionierung, soweit ich das überblicken kann. Ich kann jetzt nicht versprechen, dass ich nicht irgendwo eine Mitteilung oder einen Tweet oder whatever übersehen habe. FC Augsburg, SV Elversberg, Erster FC Kaiserslautern. Da hieß es mal, die würden mit Nein-Stimmen. Ist das bestätigt? Ich weiß es nicht. Holstein Kiel, Hansa Rostock und SVW in Wiesbaden.
Vielleicht dann nochmal kurz bei den Ablehnungen. Nicht Umkippa ist ja der falsche Ausdruck, sondern Chaled hat eben Wählerwanderung gesagt, der SC Freiburg. Sehr interessant, der war ja mit Oliver Lecky als Interimsgeschäftsführer im Mai noch bei der DFL vertreten. Und sagt jetzt dann Nein, ist der Einzige, der mir auf die Schnelle auffällt, zumindest was öffentlich bekannt ist. Gut, und bei denen noch nicht zum Abstimmungsverhalten geäußert, sollten wir zur Sicherheit auch nochmal dazu sagen, dass die SV Lbersberg und der SV Wiesbaden im Mai natürlich nicht mit abgestimmt haben, weil sie da noch in der dritten Liga waren. Das ist ja ein Punkt, den haben wir ja völlig außer Acht gelassen, dass beispielsweise Dynamo Dresden und Jan Regensburg und so jetzt oder potenzielle Aufsteiger aus der dritten Liga natürlich überhaupt nicht gefragt wurden und denen im nächsten Jahr dann irgendwie 8% der ihnen zur Verfügung stehenden Einnahmen nicht gezahlt werden, wobei das ja dann auch kommt in die...
Ja, genau. Ja, und gleichzeitig sieht man auch, also man sieht eine klare Trennung, erste Liga, zweite Liga und die hat man sowohl rhetorisch gesehen als auch, man kann sie deutlich herleiten. Also all das, was ja gerade gemacht wird, da geht es ja, also klar, Aufwertung der nationalen TV-Rechte auch, aber da, wo man wirklich wachsen will und wo man auch wirklich ein Problem hat, mit La Liga zum Beispiel Schritt zu halten, ist die Auslandsvermarktung. Und dann gucken wir uns an, wie wird dieses Geld verteilt? Da kommen, was ist es, Chaled, drei Prozent kommen überhaupt nur in der zweiten Liga an, glaube ich, von der Auslandsvermarktung.
Die Unterlagen habe ich, das kann ich dir raussuchen, wenn du mir ein bisschen Zeit gibst. Also ich weiß, dass die nationale Vermarktung oder die grundsätzliche Vermarktung, glaube ich, 80 zu 20 das Verhältnis Bundesliga, zweite Bundesliga.
Genau, und das ist aber quasi für Auslandsvermarktung noch weniger für die zweite Liga. Und deswegen ergibt es auch sehr viel Sinn, dass ich als Zweitligist sage, warum soll ich etwas an meinen zukünftigen Einnahmen abgeben, wo ich prozentual wahrscheinlich viel, viel weniger zurück bekomme. Und gleichzeitig wurden aber mal wieder, das muss man auch bei dieser zweiten Runde sagen, die rhetorischen Geschütze, die aufgefahren wurden von großen Clubs, wie eben zum Beispiel Leverkusen durch Fernando Caro, die waren wieder enorm. Also Fernando Caro hat eigentlich durch die Blume, ihr müsst mir widersprechen, wenn ihr es anders seht, aber durch die Blume hat er gesagt, ja dann spalten wir uns halt ab, wenn ihr jetzt nicht so abstimmt, wie wir das gerne hätten. Ganz egal, ob das geht oder nicht, das habt ihr ja auch sehr schön rausgearbeitet, dass das die Satzung gar nicht vorsieht und das müsste man erstmal ausgründen. Das hätte ich auch gerne gesehen, wie versucht die erste Liga, die zweite Liga loszuwerden. Aber krasser geht es ja eigentlich nicht, den anderen zu drohen und letztlich haben jetzt all dieses Konglomerat an Großklubs und an rhetorischen Geschützen, die aufgefahren wurden und an Intransparenz an den vielleicht wichtigen Stellen dann doch dazu geführt, dass wir ein ganz knappes Ergebnis bekommen, und das aber wahrscheinlich oder eventuell nur deshalb zustande gekommen ist, weil ein Abstimmungsberechtigter sich nicht an die Weisung des EV gehalten hat, in einer Entscheidung, die wahrscheinlich nie wieder zurückgedreht werden kann. Ob wir nochmal eine Bundesliga ohne Investor erleben, auch wenn das jetzt für 20 Jahre läuft, aber da können wir auch nochmal die Geschichte der Sportvermarktung uns angucken. Ich bin mir da sehr unsicher. Und das ist das, was mir eigentlich die größten Bauchschmerzen macht, bei dieser ganzen Sache, muss ich sagen.
Vielleicht auch da nochmal, wenn man mit Leuten spricht, die sich in der Private Equity-Branche auskennen, es ist äußerst, äußerst unüblich, dass ein Investor auch wirklich über die gesamte Laufzeit den Vertrag wahrnimmt oder die Beteiligung wahrnimmt. In der Regel, im Mai war es so, ich glaube es ist dieses Mal auch so, dass da reingeschrieben wurde, nach acht Jahren darf der Investor seine Anteile weitergeben. Und die DFL hat gesagt, wir haben Rückkaufsrecht, ist ja auch gut so, damit sie den Finger drauf hat.
Mit welcher Kohle wollen sie es denn zurückkaufen, wenn sie sich jetzt schon drei Millionen im Jahr nicht leisten können?
Genau, das ist halt das Thema und das sind auch Sachen, die da rein spielen, die interessant sind. Ja, ich hatte noch ein, ah nee, das war dritte Liga und DFB, der sich auch dazu nicht geäußert hat. Aber das ist jetzt nicht wichtig, obwohl ich finde es schon bemerkenswert, weil es sind halt Interessen von Drittligisten betroffen, weil du ja natürlich in der kommenden Saison wieder zwei Drittligisten da drin hast, mindestens im Bereich der DFL und der DFB hat bis heute, also ich habe es zumindest nicht gehört, nichts, aber auch rein gar nichts zu diesem Investorenprozess gesagt, obwohl Vereine unter seinem Dach und ganz streng genommen ist die DFL ja ein Mitglied des DFB und sie haben nichts gesagt.
Andreas Rettich arbeitet dort und sagt trotzdem nichts.
Das ist ja guter Besuch. Chaled, jetzt würden wir ausschweifen, wir brechen diesen Punkt hier jetzt ab.
Aber es war für euch auch eine andere Recherche jetzt ohne Andreas Rettich als Kontaktperson, der dazu einfach jetzt nichts mehr sagen will, kann, darf.
Er war gestern tatsächlich da. Also wir haben ihn kurz begrüßt, er ist mit Bernd Neuendorf rausgegangen. Die haben interessiert zugehört. Ist aber jetzt absolut üblich, dass DFB-Vertreter bei DFL-Versammlungen dabei sind. Natürlich ohne Stimmenrecht und alles.
Rettich hat das damals ganz gut erklärt, auch so die negativen Punkte in dem Podcast mit Ewald Linen, ich weiß gar nicht, wie das heißt.
Genau, der 16.
Ja, genau. Da war Rettich sehr hörenswert zum Thema. Aber ja, da kommt jetzt natürlich erst mal nichts mehr. Ich wollte noch mal eben, ihr wolltet die Verteilung des internationalen Geldes wissen eben. Das Dokument jetzt hier. Also es geht dabei um eine Plansumme von 162 Millionen Euro, die verteilt werden, heißt es, und davon werden 35 Prozent gleich verteilt, also 54 Millionen davon werden in der Bundesliga gleich verteilt und in der zweiten Bundesliga drei Millionen, so wie ich das hier sehe. So und dann wird 65 Prozent nach Leistung verteilt und dann sieht man halt schon die Unterschiede. Dann bauen die eigenen Koeffizienten über fünf Jahre und zehn Jahre. Das wird natürlich so stark verkompliziert, sage ich mal. Und da kann man aber ganz platt sehen, dass der VfL Bochum komplett leer ausgeht in diesem Bereich, während, nehmen wir mal den FC Bayern natürlich, die bekommen 20 Millionen Euro aus einem Fünf-Jahres-Koeffizient und dann nochmal 3,6 Millionen aus einem Zehn-Jahres-Koeffizient. Ja, also da sieht man schon, wo die Reise hingeht.
Genau, es ist sehr, sehr ungleich verteilt und es ergibt ja auch Sinn. Wenn wir im Leistungsprinzip Gedanken bleiben wollen, ist ja klar, dass der FC Bayern wichtiger für die Auslandsvermarktung ist als der SVW in Wiesbaden. Aber gleichzeitig ist eben beides, was ihr sagt, absolut richtig. Zum einen, dass der DFB sich gar nicht äußert, obwohl es Vereine betrifft, die unter dem Dach des DFBs aktuell in der Liga spielen und vielleicht gerade einfach nur das Pech haben, bei dieser Entscheidung nicht mit dabei zu sein, jetzt diesen Ausgleichstopf mal hingenommen. Aber wir sehen ja, es ist quasi eine Dampfer-Enterhaltung. Sehr wahrscheinlich wird das nie wieder zurückgedreht werden. Und das andere ist eben, dass letztlich die Ignoranz oder vielleicht ist es auch einfach nur öffentliches, verbalischer Mützel der Erstligisten, dass die das nicht anerkennen können, dass eigentlich Zweitligisten, die sich als Zweitligisten sehen, gar kein so großes Interesse an diesen Maßnahmen haben müssen, die es da gerade gibt. Die Zweite Liga ist ein guter Wettbewerb, die Zweite Liga ist interessant, hat immer die geringeren Quoten und so weiter, man darf das auch nicht zu sehr romantisieren, aber die Zweite Liga funktioniert besser in manchen Belangen als die Erste Liga. Das heißt, die haben es eigentlich gar nicht nötig, sich für gewisse Dinge zu öffnen. Und das ist dann schon, das muss man dann schon auch mal so deutlich benennen, weil man damit nämlich auch Probleme in der Ersten Liga, glaube ich, aufmacht, die es dann doch eigentlich zu diskutieren gäbe. Und ich habe das Gefühl, dass wir damit dann auch so ein bisschen bei der Erklärung dafür landen, warum die zweite Kernänderung, also wir hatten quasi Fokussierung auf Kapitalbedarf der DFL, wir hatten eine umfassende Transparenz. Und der dritte Punkt, das hat ja dann Mark Lenz sehr klar ausführlich noch mal beschrieben, Governance mit klaren roten Linien, die Clubs und Bietern mit Clubs und Bietern geklärt wurden, kein Zugriff auf sportliche Themen, Mitspracherechte fokussieren sich auf den wirtschaftlichen Bereich und sind klar elementiert. Und das führt eben dazu, dass wir, ich habe mir extra einen Transkript erstellt der Pressekonferenz und habe dann folgenden Remix gemacht.
Mit sehr klaren roten Linien, der roten Linien, die besagten roten Linien unserer genannten roten Linien, der klaren roten Linien, roten Linien orientieren, die wir vorgegeben haben, im Hinblick auf die roten Linien, innerhalb der roten Linien, diese roten Linien, klar auf die roten Linien hingewiesen, solche roten Linien, sehr klar innerhalb der roten Linien agieren, sogenannten roten Linien, denn es gibt Vorteile dieses Modells, das muss aber sehr klar innerhalb der roten Linien abgesichert sein.
Ich weiß nicht, ob ihr es gehört habt, liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, aber ich glaube, diese roten Linien scheinen irgendwie wichtig zu sein. 14 Mal, und ich bin nicht mal ausschließen, dass ich da noch eine rote Linie übersehen habe, wurde dieser Begriff genannt. Und das halte ich jetzt nicht nur als Gag für lustig, sondern ich glaube, das ist relevant. Chaled, kann es sein, dass gerade diese Überbetonung der roten Linien eben genau die Diskussion weglenken soll über das, was wir vorhin nämlich kurz gesprochen haben, dass es das geschriebene Wort gibt und dass es aber dann auch die Handlungspraxis gibt? Und ich komme nicht darüber hinweg, dass ich nicht glaube, dass das jetzt nur einfach Rhetorik war, dass ständig rote Linie, rote Linie, rote Linie gesagt wurde.
Ich glaube, die roten Linien sollen halt betonen, macht euch keine Sorge, wir haben die Sache im Griff. Also wir schaffen den klaren Rahmen, den es einzuhalten gilt für den Investor und für uns selbst. Da müsst ihr euch keine Sorgen machen. Ich denke, das ist die kommunikative Botschaft. Dass das über andere Dinge hinweg täuscht, kann natürlich auch Zweck der Übung sein, weiß ich nicht. Aber da sind wir wieder beim Thema Vetorechte vielleicht und so weiter, dass man da dann vielleicht noch nicht so genau weiß, wie wird sich das statuarisch war das Wort oder informell dann darstellen, wie das mit der Einflussnahme aussieht. Ich muss jetzt nervigerweise noch eine kleine Korrektur vornehmen zu dem, was ich eben gesagt habe. Die 54 Millionen bei der Auslandsvermarktung, die werden in drei Millionen Stücke geteilt. Also die 18 Clubs der Bundesliga bekommen jeder drei Millionen Euro. Also die zweite Liga, die bekommt vorher einen Teilabzug und diese 54 Millionen, die werden in drei Millionen Euro Transchen für die Clubs aufgeteilt und dann kommt das Geld von diesen Koeffizienten hinzu. Entschuldigung für den Themensprung.
Ja, aber wir sind bei den roten Linien, Marcus. Also das wurde es eben ganz oft uns gesagt. Wir haben es vorhin schon ein bisschen diskutiert, dass man das aufweichen kann. Ist die eigentliche rote Linie nicht eigentlich dieser Beschluss gewesen, der jetzt gefasst wurde und der die überschritten wurde?
Ja, aus Sicht vieler Fans und auch vieler Kritiker mit Sicherheit, weil du holst jetzt jemanden ins Boot, der dir reinreden kann. Das ist definitiv so. Man fragt sich halt nur, was der genau bestimmen kann und der muss ja, wie soll ich das jetzt sagen, der wird ja wahrscheinlich oder der kommt aus der Fußball fremden, nein, machen wir ja nicht, aber ich weiß jetzt ehrlich gesagt nicht, wie ich es ausdrücke, aber der hat ja andere Interessen.
Die kommen aus einer wirtschaftlichen Sphäre mit einem wirtschaftlichen Blick. Denen ist der Sport ehrlich gesagt erstmal scheißegal. Also keiner von den Investoren, der reingeht, sagt, ich mach das, weil mein Hart schlägt für den Fußball und das meiner Investoren. Ne, so funktioniert es ja eigentlich.
Genau das wollte ich sagen. Wobei, machen wir uns nichts vor, Bundesliga sind ja natürlich auch Wirtschaftsunternehmen, aber halt auch noch Fußballvereine. Aber ein Private Equity Unternehmen ist halt nur ein Wirtschaftsunternehmen. Und das auch noch was darauf auf ist, nach größtmöglicher Rendite zu gucken. Das spielt ja alles andere. Ich meine, dafür geben die Leute ja halt ihr Geld, damit die da möglichst viel rausmachen. Je mehr man hat, desto gieriger ist man. Das kennen wir alle.
Ich finde, es gibt eine spannende Detailfrage dabei auch. Wenn wir uns mal diese Unternehmen, das wird ja jetzt die Aufgabe der nächsten Wochen werden, angucken, die da einen Einstieg planen. Es gibt ja nun eine gewisse Wahrscheinlichkeit oder eine Favoritenrolle, sagen wir mal unausgesprochen, für diese Jungs von CWC oder CFC, wie auch immer. Die haben den Deal mit der französischen Liga gemacht, die jetzt den 390 Award bekommen werden für den Vertrag des Jahres logischerweise. Sie haben den Deal mit der spanischen Liga. Sie sind im Frauentennis bei der WTA investiert. Sie waren bei der Formel 1, haben da ziemlich viel auf den Kopf gestellt. Da stellt sich natürlich die Frage, wenn du so viele Investments hast, die alle am selben Markt für TV-Geld antreten, bestehen dann da irgendwann Interessenkonflikte, dass du halt quasi das Zweite deiner Investments Geld benötigen und welchen drückst du nach vorne und welchen hältst du ein bisschen zurück in den Verhandlungen? Das ist ja denkbar. Da wurde uns gesagt, dass es dann dafür dann so einzelne Abteilungen, Büros gibt zwischen denen bestimmten Chinese Walls. Chinese Walls. So, es ist aber ein Hauptargument dafür, das überhaupt zu machen, dass man das Know-how und das Netzwerk nutzt. Und da frage ich mich, was denn jetzt? Chinese Walls oder Netzwerk? Also das ist so ein bisschen...
Plus wir hatten ja noch rausgearbeitet im letzten Tribünengespräch, CWC hat auch 2050 80 Prozent an Sky Batting gekauft und 2016 die Mehrheit an Tipico. Und da kommen wir jetzt dann zurück. Also viele haben jetzt Witze gemacht über das Namensrecht der Bundesliga. Das ist eigentlich schon wieder so ein kleiner Decoy, weil das hat jetzt genuin gar nichts mit dem Investor zu tun. Aber wenn irgendwann die Tipico Bundesliga vom Investor CWC mitvermarktet wird, also es gibt eben Interessenskonflikte, die da sind. Und gleichzeitig gibt es auch den Fakt, also wir hatten ja als mögliche Interessenten CWC, Blackstone, EQ2 und Advent. Wir sind da dann im Detail gar nicht mehr so genau drauf eingegangen, weil wir die Ablehnung der Investorenerscheinungen hatten. Wenn man sich allerdings mit all diesen Unternehmen und Investoren befasst, dann sieht man, CWC sind eigentlich die einzigen von denen, die wirklich eine sportliche Kompetenz haben und die aber deswegen auch schon in ganz vielen Wettbewerben, Rugby kommt zum Beispiel auch noch mit dazu, schon mit drin hingen. Wo dann aber auch die Frage ist, wenn wir dann auch sehen, CWC hängt bei der Ligue 1 drin, hängt bei La Liga drin. Und ich glaube, bei der Serie A, genau, da waren sie noch in den Verhandlungen. Das ist nicht so gekommen, aber war ursprünglich damals noch der Plan, ist dann gescheitert an anderen Dingen. Dann ist ja auch die Frage, welchen Vorteil kann die Bundesliga denn davon haben, dass dieser Investor mit drin ist, der in allen anderen Ligen auch drin hängt. Aber die kann einem keiner beantworten.
Beim Rugby hatten sie auch nicht so viele rote Linien, glaube ich.
Beim Rugby sind die einmal schön durch. Ja, die wollten und auf den Abstieg sollte eingeführt dann wieder abgeschafft werden. In Südafrika waren sie da noch drin in einem nationalen Markt beim Rugby. Bei der Formel 1, du hast es so gesagt, aber CWC ist wesentlich dafür verantwortlich, dass Formel 1 von FreeTV ins PayTV geschoben wurde. Also ganz, ganz großer Eingriff, der im Fußball jetzt ganz anders begleitet werden würde, wenn so was Ähnliches passieren würde.
Aber auch eine klare Wirkrichtung USA, wo ja gerade alle hinziehen.
Genau, drei Rennen jetzt in den USA und so weiter.
Der vielversprechende Zukunftsmarkt. Drei Rennen haben die in den USA, genau.
Welche Sprintrennen noch mit dazu eingeführt. Also wer sich mit der Geschichte der Formel 1 befasst. Und das ist ja interessant, weil das ist das Role Model. Alle sagen Drive to Survive. Mit jedem Bundesliga-Vertreter, mit dem Sprechst alle sagen, so eine tolle Serie. Aber das Drive to Survive auch bedeutet, dass du quasi einen Markt für Formel 1 interessiert, der A den Sport vielleicht gar nicht so versteht. Also manche haben ja gar nicht verstanden, dass das quasi nicht live ist, Drive to Survive. Es gab Leute, die gesagt haben, jetzt bin ich aber gespannt, ob er wirklich Weltmeister wird, Max Verstappen. Und das ist jetzt schon ein paar Wochen her. Okay, alles klar. Aber das Zweite ist, das bedeutet auch einen krassen Eingriff in den kompletten Wettbewerb, wenn du wirklich Drive to Survive umsetzen möchtest.
Du siehst auch einfach, wie sie diese USA-Vermarktung vorangetrieben haben. Da ziehen jetzt auch alle hin. Und dann ist ja auch wieder die Frage, kannst du gegen diese Konkurrenz überhaupt groß anstinken, gerade wenn die Engländer das so machen?
Natürlich nicht. Also die Frage muss man doch gar nicht stellen. Also das ist doch, wie soll denn... Es tut mir leid, aber ich will nichts gegen die Vereine per se sagen. Aber wie soll denn Augsburg gegen Hoffenheim irgendwie gegen alles andere bestehen, was es in den USA gibt? US-Sport, La Liga, die Premier League. Natürlich funktioniert das nicht. Irgendwann wird... Irgendwann kommt die gläserne Decke. Wir sehen sie doch eigentlich schon, die gläserne Decke. Wir kommen doch durch die gläserne Decke gerade nur noch durch, indem wir uns in Investoren reinholen. Aber dieses Bewusstsein möchte einfach nicht durchsickern bei den Vereinsvertretern, weil sie sich dann nämlich umdrehen müssten und sagen müssten, ach so, da müssen wir ja gucken, was wir mit dem jetzigen Geld machen und wie wir es ausgeben. Und da ist eben einfach ein Pile of shit dahinter, weil sie einfach super, super schlecht im Wirtschaften sind. Das muss man einfach mal so klar benennen. Nicht die Einzelperson, die Strukturen als Gesamtes, Fußballunternehmen sind wahnsinnig schlecht in der Ausgabenreduzierung und deswegen müssen sie immer weiter. Aber natürlich wird das nicht funktionieren. Ich finde, diese Frage muss man gar nicht stellen und dann darf man sich auch nicht auf irgendwelche Debatten einlassen. Du wirst mit der Premier League sowieso nie mithalten können. Und jetzt geht es ja schon um Rang 2 hinter der Premier League. Erklär mir einfach mal, wie du mit La Liga mithalten willst, die einen sprachlichen Vorteil haben, die einen sozio-kulturellen Vorteil haben und die ja jetzt auch schon viel, viel weiter sind, was alles Digitale angeht. Also alles, was die Bundesliga macht, muss erst mal im ersten Versuch so gut sein wie La Liga. Und dann haben die aber schon das drei Jahre weiterentwickelt. Das wird nicht funktionieren.
Es gibt halt diesen zeitlichen Vorsprung, genau. Was aber ganz interessant ist, wo du gerade Italien angesprochen hast. Die haben das hier noch nicht gemacht, so ein Deal. Und auch wenn da dieses Thema immer wieder da war. Und ich bin darauf gekommen, tatsächlich über das Rasenfunk-Forum aus dem letzten Gespräch. Da gab es den Hinweis, dass, oh Gott, wie heißt der? Gary Cardinale von Redbird, das sind die Besitzer von Milan. Und der hat gesagt, auf keinen Fall lasse ich Private Equity in die Liga rein, was bemerkenswert ist, weil er einem Private Equity-Unternehmen vorstellt. Also er will das alles selber machen. Was soll es dir bringen, dieses Geld reinzuholen? Du hast gar keine richtige Verwendung dafür und du musst unter 20 Clubs aufteilen. Was soll das bringen, fragt er halt bei diesem legendären Financial Times Summit, der einmal im Jahr ist. Und das war ganz interessant. Aber gleichzeitig ist Milan genau der Beleg dafür. Ich meine, klar, Augsburg und Hoffenheim werden es auch gegen Milan schwer haben, jetzt so vom Bekanntheitsgrad, klar. Aber Milan, die haben eine ganz bemerkenswerte Geschichte hingelegt zuletzt. Die waren komplett im Eimer mit diesem chinesischen Besitzer, der dann seine Schulden bei Redbird, glaube ich, nicht mehr bezahlen könnte und so ist dieser Club relativ billig in die Hände von Redbird gekommen. Und Redbird, wie der Name schon sagt, die wollten eigentlich Liverpool haben. Die haben es halt geschafft, diesen Club, der war ja völlig im Eimer, die waren in der Europa League gesperrt wegen Financial Fair Play Verstößen, sowas passiert tatsächlich schon mal. Dann hatten die eine überalterte Mannschaft noch mit Ibrahimovic und so und die haben das halt wirklich komplett wieder getrimmt. Die haben diesen Club zur Meisterschaft in Italien geführt, was sehr bemerkenswert angesichts dieser Ewigkeitsserie, die sich anbahnte mit Juventus Turin damals noch, und wieder fit für die Champions League gemacht. Das Interessante ist aber, es ist eine äußerst beliebte Sportmarke in den USA geworden. Und wie haben die das geschafft, ist ja die Frage, weil sie haben ja eigentlich auch diesen soziokulturellen sprachlichen Nachteil, wie ihnen die Bundesliga hätte. Also italienisch außerhalb von New York kommst du nicht mit weit. Und die haben halt eine Kooperation mit den New York Yankees begonnen und haben angefangen, gegenseitig das Merchandise auch zu verkaufen. Und die tauschen Vorstände tatsächlich aus gegenseitig. Die Milan-Spiele werden in diesem Yankees-TV übertragen. Also die haben sich richtig in den USA verankert. Und alle Geschäftszahlen, ob es nur daran liegt, sei mal dahingestellt, aber alle Geschäftszahlen zeigen knallhart nach oben. Während Inter das totale Sorgenkind geworden ist finanziell in Italien, ist Milan, denen geht es fantastisch gerade.
Da ist nur die Frage, wer sich an die Patriots und Oliver Bierhoff schmeißt.
Weg vom Tegernsee ist ja nicht so weit.
Ich würde noch mal gerne zu CBC kommen und dann zu einem anderen Punkt, weil in der Vorberichterstattung war ja auch zu hören, dass die DFL oder dass es im Gespräch ist, CBC auszuschliehen als Ausschlussklausel. Sie sind schon in anderen Ligen, deshalb nehmen wir dich nicht. Davon war jetzt überhaupt nicht die Rede und das führt mich zu einem Punkt, den wir heute auch noch gar nicht angesprochen haben und den ich für so gravierend halte, dass ich wirklich die Leute oder viele der Vereine nicht verstehe, die mit Ja gestimmt haben, weil der große Unterschied zu Mai ist. Da hätten die Clubs beschlossen mit einem Ja, wir führen den Prozess weiter. Das wird ausverhandelt und dann zur Abstimmung gestellt und jetzt haben sie der Geschäftsführung, der sie vertrauen und wahrscheinlich zu Recht vertrauen, quasi einen Blankoscheck gegeben. Ihr verhandelt das und ihr macht das und wenn dann hinterher herauskommt, die machen mit einer Heuschrecke, die das Geld aus Saudi-Arabien oder so, ja dann kann der Verein, Moment, wer hat dafür gestimmt, dann kann Werder Brehmer sagen, das wollten wir jetzt eigentlich nicht, aber dann sagt die DFL, ja Leute, das ist jetzt weit zu spät, da hätte er euch am 11. Dezember überlegen können. Also dieses Mitspracherecht hätte ich mir unter keinen Umständen aus der Hand nehmen lassen. Und das zeigt aber auch mal, das zeigt halt auch, was für ein Druck da drauf war, auch zeitlich und dass die da zugestimmt haben. Also es ist für mich unverständlich, dass da Vereine zugestimmt haben unter den Voraussetzungen.
Man muss fairerweise dazu sagen, dass die Herkunft des Geldes ist ganz schwer nachverfolgbar. Das bleibt doch ein Kritikpunkt. Und in dem FAQ von der DFL selbst ist das aber auch kurz angesprochen, dass sie sagen wollen, wir wollen Klarheit darüber, wo das Geld herkommt. Und dass es dann da auch, ich sage es jetzt nochmal, rote Linien gibt.
Sie wollen zwar keine Klarheit, wie man dem Kind abgestimmt hat, aber wo das Geld herkommt.
Vielleicht können die Geldgeber ihr Geld anonym in die Urne werfen oder so.
Das wurde ja im Frühjahr auch schon viel besprochen, weil wir ja wissen, dass quasi das Geld, was gerade noch da ist, das kommt halt viel aus Saudi-Arabien und so weiter. Und du würdest vielleicht gerne das Geld haben, aber du möchtest nicht die Diskussion rund und das Geld haben. Da ist aber auch interessant, dass es ja also bei den Anbietern, bei den Interessenten unterschiedlich ist bei den Investoren. Also manchmal hängen da Rentenfonds mit drin, manchmal hängt da klassisches Venture Capital mit drin. Sie werden da irgendeinen Good Governance-Bericht vorlegen, aber ob der dann wirklich so stimmt. Also bei CWC zum Beispiel, die sitzen in Luxemburg und haben über 500 Investoren. Viele von denen sollen schon seit den frühen 90ern mit dabei sein. Werden wir die Liste dieser Investoren sehen, können wir dann nachvollziehen bei jedem einzelnen Investor, woher das ist. Wer sein Geld hat. Ich möchte es anzweifeln, weil so funktioniert das auch in diesem Bereich nicht. Das ist... und Blackstone zum Beispiel, die wurden damals gegründet von zwei Investmentbankern, der Lehman Brothers Bank. Weiß ich nicht, ob das jetzt schon irgendwie so einen Hinweis darauf gibt, wie die arbeiten. EQT, die auch im Gespräch waren, die sind in Deutschland bisher vor allem im Gesundheitsbereich unterwegs gewesen, haben sich einen Glasfaser-Hersteller gekauft für 1,1 Milliarden. Das ist übrigens die deutsche Glasfaser, also die ist ja auch sehr, sehr wichtig in einem infrastrukturellen Bereich in Deutschland. Und Advent, die noch möglicher interessant sind, die haben sich von ganz, ganz unterschiedlichen Orten Geld zusammengezogen. Da ist es auch extrem schwer nachzuvollziehen. Und wer sich für diesen ganzen Bereich interessiert, der kann mal nachgoogeln, 777 und woher die ihr Geld haben. Das ist ein ganz eigener Bereich, da wird es nie Klarheit geben und es ist okay, dass das thematisiert wird. Aber ich glaube eben auch, das ist eine ablenkende Diskussion. Und das, was du gesagt hast, Marcus, das ist wirklich eigentlich der total wichtige Punkt. Man hat die Entscheidung aus der Hand gegeben. Ich würde aber die These in den Raum stellen, vielleicht ganz gerne. Denn dadurch, dass man das jetzt anders gemacht hat, als im Frühjahr, eben dass das jetzt quasi beschlossen wird, ohne noch mal in eine große Abstimmung zu gehen, ist vielleicht auch die Möglichkeit da, dass mancher Verein sagen kann, ja, ein bisschen Bauchschmerzen haben wir damit jetzt schon, aber jetzt wurde es halt so abgestimmt, da konnten wir jetzt auch nicht mehr hingehen. Das ist so ein bisschen so, wie sich nationale Gesetzgeber gegenüber der EU manchmal verhalten. Sie hätten es eigentlich mitgestalten können, sagen dann aber, die doofe EU, was hat die da wieder beschlossen? Also ich bin mir nicht sicher, ob das nicht sogar gewollt ist. Gleichzeitig gibt es hier aber noch einen weiteren Konflikt in den Darstellungen, der nicht auflösbar ist. Und zwar, wir hören es mal kurz noch an, was Steffen Merkley jetzt sagt, zu wie es jetzt eigentlich weitergeht. Denn das ist jetzt auch die konkrete Frage. Und dann erkläre ich kurz, warum ich da noch einen Widerspruch erkenne.
Ich kann Ihnen sagen, dass wir in den letzten Tagen bereits die Interessenbekundungen mehrer Interessenten und das sind allesamt Interessenbekundungen, die aus unserer Sicht sehr, sehr wertehaltig sind, sich auch dem Grundsatz nach an den roten Linien orientieren, die wir vorgegeben haben, dass uns diese vorliegen. Wie wir jetzt genau weitermachen, das werden wir bereits morgen in einer Sitzung des DFL-Präsidiums besprechen, die stattfinden wird, der würde ich jetzt ungern an der Stelle vorgreifen. Es werden aber sicherlich, und das ist in solchen Prozessen üblich, mehrere Interessenten sein, mit denen wir weitermachen im nächsten Prozessschritt.
Also wahrscheinlich in der Sekunde, in der wir jetzt zusammensitzen, das ist nämlich das Morgen, das er gerade angesprochen hat im O-Ton, wird besprochen, wie es konkret weitergeht. Und da möchte ich jetzt aber noch mal einen Widerspruch aufzeigen. Also auf der einen Seite sind alle Interessenten sagen, die roten Linien finden wir mega geil, haben wir richtig Bock drauf, Mitsprache ist ja auch eigentlich ein bisschen langweilig, haben wir schon bei all unseren anderen Investments, wollen wir nicht. Auf der anderen Seite gibt es mehrere Interessenten, die gesagt haben, trotz dieser für den Investmentbereich untypisch krassen Einschränkungen haben wir Interesse daran. Und obwohl man dieses Interesse hat, kann man jetzt aber den Prozess nicht später stattfinden lassen. Also ja, diese Entscheidung hat ein Signal auf die nationale TV-Rechtevergabe, das hat Steffen Merkel gesagt. Aber wäre das so viel anders gewesen, wenn man jetzt gesagt hätte, wir setzen das ganz in Ruhe auf und wir treffen diese Investorenentscheidung erst nach der TV-Rechtevergabe. Ich weiß nicht, Marcus, wie du das siehst, aber irgendwie, finde ich, passt das auch nicht so ganz zusammen. Also entweder die Interessenten haben richtig Bock, dann kann man sich doch aber eigentlich auch noch ein bisschen mehr Zeit lassen oder es ist halt doch alles nicht ganz so einfach, Geld einzusammeln an diesen Markt und deswegen muss man es jetzt noch vor der TV-Rechtevergabe im Frühjahr unbedingt durchgedrückt haben.
Also dieser zeitliche Druck vor der TV-Rechtevergabe, der war da auf jeden Fall drauf, das haben sie auch zugegeben. Ich glaube sogar gestern in der PK an anderer Stelle, ich weiß es gar nicht genau. Ja, Widersprüche siehst du, das hast du sehr gut rausgearbeitet. Das sieht man in einigen Sachen. Also ich glaube, dass das gehört, weil als wir gefragt haben, wenn das Ding jetzt in die Buchse geht, dann war es das aber auch. Und da wurde gesagt, also von Seite der Private Equity Unternehmen eigentlich gar nicht, weil die verhalten den Deal nach wie vor für interessant. Und das natürlich nur, weil sie eine Riesenrendite wittern, weil sie halt diese schlechte Ausgangsverhandlungsausgangslage der DFL ausnutzen wollen. Wir können das übrigens, wenn ich das richtig gehört habe, hat Merkel gerade gesagt, wir verhandeln mit oder alle vier Angebote sind werthaltig. War das nicht so? Also da haben wir was anderes gehört. Wir haben gehört, dass drei so sind, dass man sagen kann, da würden wir von den Reaktdaten jederzeit abschließen. Deshalb ist die Gefahr, dass das jetzt noch platzt, auch äußerst gering. Und einer müsse noch irgendwie nachbessern. Ich glaube, der hat bisher 800 Millionen gewonnen. Also die anderen irgendwie was zwischen 900 und 1 Milliarde. So, jetzt habe ich den Pfaden verloren. Wo wollten wir drauf? Ach so, die Widersprüche. Ja, die Widersprüche gibt es nicht nur in dem Punkt. Es passt vieles noch nicht zusammen. Aber wenn man alles zusammenkehrt, kommen wir, glaube ich, zu dem Schluss, dass ein Riesendruck da drauf war. Und wenn es jetzt vor Weihnachten 2023 nicht passiert wäre, dann wäre es wohl wirklich nicht mehr passiert, weil die, wie gesagt, ich habe es ja heute Morgen auch geschrieben, gestern sagte einer, wir sind ein zerstrikener Haufen, auch so wie wir uns darstellen. Und das kann man ja jetzt auch noch so sehen. Also zwölf Nein-Stimmen bzw. Enthaltungen. Und viele sehen die Widersprüche da und unter den Ja-Sagern werden halt viele Widersprüche sehen, aber vor allen Dingen auch das Geld, was sie dann nicht aus eigener Tasche bezahlen müssen. Und von daher sagen sie ja, also, ich würde sagen, wir bleiben da dran. Und es wird eher spannender als langweiliger, das ganze Thema.
Ja, den Eindruck habe ich auch.
Die spannenden Fragen sind jetzt Hannover, wie es da im Binnenverhältnis vor allem weitergeht. Und ja, natürlich jetzt, wer es wird und in welchen Rahmenbedingungen der Investor kommt, was du eben angesprochen hast, Marcus, das war bei einem der kritischen Clubs. Da wurde über das Argument gesprochen, dass man jetzt natürlich diese Investoren vergrault, wenn man jetzt ein zweites Mal sich nervig und zerstritten dann präsentiert. Und er meinte, der Deal ist für den Investor so gut, es gibt kein Vergraulen. Die würden auch ein drittes Mal kommen, weil da einfach eine ganze Menge Kohle zu holen ist.
Das ist es nämlich. Und das sollte einen doch wirklich aufmerksam werden lassen. Da müssen sich doch alle Lauscherchen aufstellen, wenn Investoren so geil darauf sind, in diese Liga einzusteigen. Warum? Und ist es dann so, weil wir alle im Paradies leben werden in 20 Jahren und der Investor und alle anderen Beteiligten gleichermaßen reicher geworden sind? Oder liegt das vielleicht an anderen Gründen? Weil das vielleicht für Investoren gerade ein Moment ist, in dem der Sport wirtschaftlich in der Krise ist, reinzugehen in einen Markt, der einzigartig ist, weil eben das Produkt live Sport nicht zu ersetzen ist. Da brauchen wir keine Diskussionen machen, Merchandising usw. Das Wichtigste sind aber die TV-Rechte. Deswegen wollen da so viele rein. Weil es auch irgendwie ein ganz geiler Markt ist. Manche schmücken sich auch gerne damit. Aber wir haben eben jetzt nicht mehr die Einzemilliardäre, die irgendwo reingehen und sich ein Spielzeug zulegen, weil sie schon immer großer FC Chelsea-Fan waren zum Beispiel. Sondern jetzt haben wir Unternehmen, die, ihr könnt euch, also man kann auf die Seiten all dieser Anbieter gehen. Zum Teil kann man sich da dann oder was heißt zum Teil, überall kannst du dir die Quartalsberichte und so weiter runterladen. Und da sind dann die Einzelinvestments, das sind ganz, ganz kleine Punkte in einer großen Liste, wo einfach nur da steht, da haben wir zwei Milliarden mehr gemacht, Steigerung um 14 Prozent, mega geil. Dann haben wir noch die die Krankenhauskette gekauft, da erwarten wir auch eine Steigerung im nächsten Jahr. Und einer dieser Bullet Points wird dann die Bundesliga sein. Und da muss man sich ja keine Illusionen machen. Da bin ich jetzt ja gar nicht irgendwie jemand, der schwarz malt, sondern jeder, der sich mit Venture Capital auseinandersetzt, der sagt, ja, so funktioniert dieser Markt. Und wenn Venture Capital in einen Markt rein will, dann sagt das sehr viel darüber aus, in welcher Verfassung dieser Markt gerade ist. Und das haben wir jetzt in der Bundesliga. Und das hätten wir aber auch, wenn jetzt, die hätten sich intern wahrscheinlich sehr zerstritten, wenn die das jetzt abgelehnt hätten und wahrscheinlich hätte Karo wirklich mal prüfen lassen, ey, können wir die erste Liga nicht irgendwie ausgliedern aus der DFL? Aber ansonsten wäre nichts passiert. Die Investoren wären in einem Jahr und noch da gewesen. Und jetzt sind sie aber, weil die Vereine gerade in einer Position der Schwäche sind. Und warum sind sie in der Position der Schwäche? Weil sie zugunsten des sportlichen Wettbewerbs ganz schlecht wirtschaften. In Summe. Nicht alle für sich genommen, aber in Summe wirtschaften sie schlecht. Und weil es einige Vereine gibt, die auch schlecht wirtschaften können und dafür nie sportlich bestraft wurden. Also sprich, weil der Wettbewerb ausgehört wurde durch die 50 plus 1 Ausnahmen. Irgendwie bin ich an dem Punkt, da lasse ich da auch keine Diskussion mehr zu, ehrlich gesagt. Weil ich höre das immer, wenn ich dann mit den Leuten aus den Vereinen spreche. Aber diese basalen Wahrheiten sind doch da.
Völlige Zustimmung. Und was du gerade gut auf den Punkt gebracht hast, ist, dass es jetzt auch gilt, den Blick zu weiten. Dass wir jetzt, wir bewegen uns bei der ganzen Diskussion. Wir nehmen die Fußballperspektive komplett ein. Also wir sprechen wirklich immer nur, was ist das für die DFL, was bedeutet das für die Clubs und so weiter. Aber mal von oben drauf zu gucken aus Sicht dieser Investoren oder den Blick auf diese Investoren. Das wird jetzt die nächste Aufgabe sein, da mal aus diesem Fußballkosmos auszubrechen und sich, ja, auf meinen Wirtschaftsredaktionen der Kollegen zu melden. Ja, wir machen diese Themen ja eigentlich immer Spaß, diese Wirtschaftsthemen im Fußball. Ich sage ja immer, diese Fußballpolitik, die macht mir immer deswegen besonders viel Freude, während auf dem Platz immer Bayern München gewinnt und es da immer langweiliger wird. Passiert da immer was Unerwartendes. Es hat so was Netflix-artiges. Ich habe auch gestern gesagt, diese Abstimmung über einen Investor könnte man hervorragend vermarkten, wie den Deadline. Jetzt haben wir zwei Abstimmungen. Es steht ja eigentlich 1 zu 1. Das Abstimmungsergebnis von damals, kann man ja nicht behaupten, dass das respektiert worden ist. Jetzt steht es 1 zu 1. Lass uns doch einfach Best of 5 machen. Nein, abgeschafft. Ich bin der größte Auswärtstorregel-Gegner. Auswärtstorregel mache ich gerne. Lass uns doch Best of 5 machen. Und dann machen wir so Deadline-Day-mäßig, so Confirmed, Schalke 04, wechselt von Nein zu Ja oder so.
Ich habe noch mal eine Frage. Das habe ich mir jetzt aufgeschrieben, weil ich das so indirekt aus deinen Ausführungen abgeleitet habe, Max. Und ich habe ehrlich gesagt überhaupt keine Ahnung. Das ist auch etwas, womit man sich beschäftigen muss. Ziel dieser ganzen Aktion ist ja auch, Daten von Fans zu bekommen. Wie lassen sich Daten monetarisieren? Und wie sieht es mit Datenschutz aus? Kannst du das oder …Nicht, wenn wir in der Zeit bleiben wollen.
Also wir bleiben da dran. Wir machen das nochmal ausführlicher. Aber grundsätzlich ist es so, du kannst natürlich zielgerichtetes Marketing machen, du kannst Daten weiterverkaufen und du kannst Daten mit anderen Daten verknüpfen. Also ich lese gerade von Shoshana Sabev das Buch The Age of Surveillance Capitalism und da erklärt sie eigentlich ganz gut, dass das das Geschäftsmodell von Amazon, von Microsoft und von Meta sowie von Google ist und wie sich das eigentlich dahin entwickeln konnte, dass da auch Privatsphäre eigentlich nichts mehr wert ist. Da müsste ich jetzt tatsächlich in einen langen Exkurs gehen. Es ist aber tatsächlich so heutzutage, wenn du in skalierenden Geschäftsmodellen im digitalen Bereich Geld verdienen willst, dann sind Daten, die generiert werden und die dann einen Mehrwert erzeugen über verschiedene Geschäftsmodelle, sind nicht mehr wegzudenken. Das ist tatsächlich so, wie diese Art des Kapitalismus funktioniert, was aber halt verheerend ist für unsere Privatsphäre, verheerend ist auch für die Privatsphäre dann von Fußballfans und wo definitiv datenschutzrechtliche Bestimmungen ein Thema werden würden, denn da ist ja Deutschland und die EU ein bisschen, ein bisschen restriktiver aufgestellt als die US-Märkte und alles müsste aber DSGVO konform sein zum Beispiel und das will ich dann erst mal sehen. Da will ich den Datenschutz beauftragten der Media Co., mit dem will ich dann eine Standleitung haben. Da bitte ich jetzt schon.
Alles klar, dann sind wir jetzt bei Fatuna Düsseldorf, deshalb schenken die ja Karten, da sind wir bei 50 plus 1 und Mitgliedervotum und deshalb haben wir die Sache jetzt rund gemacht, denke ich mal. Ich glaube, ich brauche jetzt auch mal, ich hoffe nicht, dass Hannover heute irgendwie durchdreht, brauche mal anderthalb Tage ohne rote Linien und Investor.
Ja, ich glaube, das geht uns allen so. Ein letztes, diese rote Linien habe ich aber hier noch, ich habe es extra mir auf Soundboard gelegt, es musste nochmal eingespielt werden. Ihr zwei, das war nicht die letzte Sendung, glaube ich. Wir werden an dem Thema dranbleiben. Ich danke euch sehr, sehr herzlich. Eure Berichterstattung war auch zusammen mit der von Benny Hofmann vom Kicker. Herausragend, es war wie ein Live-Ticker, es hat mir extrem geholfen. Und mich freut es dann aber auch zu hören, dass das Forum dir auch geholfen hat, Chaled, also mitmachen.rasenfunk.de, da kann man wirklich interessante Dinge lesen. Da gibt es auch ein Fußball-Business-Thread, das ist ein absolutes Klein-Od, da kann man sehr viel Zeit verlieren. Also danke euch für eure Zeit, Chaled, danke dir, dass du mit dabei warst. Und herzlichen Dank an Marcus Bark, der im Laufe dieser Sendung zu einer transzendenten Erscheinung wurde, weil ihm die Sonne so ins Gesicht scheint.
Es ist unglaublich. Ich habe gestern noch, wie gesagt, ich habe seit drei Wochen keine trockenen Straßen in Dortmund mehr gesehen und nicht die Sonne. Und jetzt scheint die seit einer Stunde. Es ist fantastisch.
Das wundert mich gar nicht. Jetzt wurde Investoreneinstieg beschlossen. Da kommt in Dortmund die Sonne raus. Die hat Akiwatske ganz persönlich bestellt. Also danke dir, dass du mit dabei warst.
Der wird dann noch schneller wieder gesund. Das sollten wir vielleicht noch schnell erwähnen, weil der gestern gar nicht zu Wort kam und nicht bei der PK war. Der war schlicht nicht da, weil er krank ist derzeit.
Ah, okay, ja, stimmt. Gute Erwähnung. Und nachdem wir so lange über nicht Sozialismus, sondern über Kapitalismus gesprochen haben und über Investoren, liebe Leute, wenn ihr euch da draußen fragt, gibt es denn keinen guten Ort, an dem ich mein Geld noch einsetzen kann? Doch, den gibt es im Rasenfunk. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Wir sind rein crowdfinanziert aus Gründen, die man auch aus diesem Segment hier ableiten kann. Wir wollen eben unabhängig sein. Und ihr könnt uns inzwischen auch über PayPal und Kreditkarte unterstützen. rasenfunk.de/supportersclub. Bitte crowdfundet dieses Projekt hier weiter für Sendungen dieser Art. Und dann danke für eure Aufmerksamkeit. Auf rasenfunk.de gibt es noch ganz ganz viele andere Sendungen. Bitte empfehlt uns weiter und bis bald hier wieder im Rasenfunk. Bleibt gesund. Das war der Rasenfunk.
Wir geben nun zurück in die angeschlossenen Funkhäuser.
Rasenfunk unterstützen ihr KNAUSA.